ASSEMBLY LABOR COMMITTEE
AND BEFORE- I MAKE SOME OPENING
REMARKS AND OFFER MY COLLEAGUES
TO MAKE OPEN MYSELF LIKE DO YOU
CITY COUNCIL RARE AND EDWARDS-
TO WALK. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
IT REALLY IS AN HONOR TO HAVE
OUR ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AND
SACRAMENTO IN THIS PARTICULAR
CONVENING HERE IN OUR CHAMBERS
IN RIVERSIDE CITY I AM A
COUNCIL MEMBER THE REPRESENTS
THE FIRST WARD HERE IN
RIVERSIDE IN DISCUSSING THE
WAREHOUSE INDUSTRY AND
WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND THE FACT
THAT THIS HAS ON EVERYONE THE
BENEFITS AND THE CONCERNS THAT
THIS HASN'T COMMUNITIES IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD. TO THE STATION TODAY
AND I KNOW THAT AS EARLY AS
TUESDAY OF NEXT WEEK THE TENT
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT A
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN FOR THE AND
TALKING ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
THEIR HOUSES IN ONE PARTICULAR
NEIGHBORHOOD ON THE NORTH SIDE
SO THIS IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT I THE REST OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE EAGER TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
ALL OF YOU. FOR BEING HERE. HE
SOME COUNSELOR FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR HAVING US- THIS
BEAUTIFUL CHAMBER AND FIRST
TIME ON HERE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATED. AND I LIKE TO
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. ON THE WAREHOUSE AND
SUPPLY CHAIN INDUSTRIES. AND SO
THIS IS MY SECOND YEAR AS CHAIR
OF THE LABOR COMMITTEE AND
BEEN. HOLDING INFORMATION
HEARINGS AROUND THE STATE.
ANOTHER FRIDAY TOPICS UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF FUTURE WORK AND THE
CHANGES AND CHALLENGES THAT WE-
HAD IN OUR CALIFORNIA KIND OF
AND- I THIRTY INTENTIONALLY. DO
IT IN DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
AROUND THE STATE BECAUSE
IMPORTANT I THINK FOR US TO GET
OUTSIDE OF THAT SACRAMENTO
BUBBLE AND ACTUALLY HEAR FROM
ACADEMICS TO WORKERS FROM THOSE
THAT MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE INVOICE WE MAY BE
ON A REGULAR BASIS I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO GO TO
REGION'S IN THE STATE- THAT.
AFFECTED OR- WILL SOON BE
AFFECTED BY SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN TALKING A
LOT ABOUT. THE RECENT YEARS.
AND SO TODAY WE CONTINUE. THIS
SERIES OF HEARINGS ON THE
FUTURE WORK WITH THE- DEEP DIVE
INTO CONDITIONS. FACING
WAREHOUSES HYGIENE WORKERS. AND
THE IMPACT OF TECHNOLOGY ON
THAT WORK. I'M VERY HONORED TO
BE JOINED BY TWO OF MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY SOME MEMBER
JOSE MEDINA WHOSE DISTRICT. IN
TODAY- DOES ALL THIS IN THE
NUMBER OF MOVIES WHEREAS. IN
THE NEIGHBORING DISTRICT. BOTH
OF THEM A STAUNCH ADVOCATE OF
FOR RIVERSIDE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE- WHEN THEY'RE UP IN
SACRAMENTO THEY MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR TO THIS REGION. NEEDS TO
HAVE A STRONG VOICE. LABEL BY.
TO STRONG VOICE IN SACRAMENTO
ALL. IN THIS REGION. THE LAST
PEOPLE FEW MONTHS. NUMBER
SUPPORT OF HIGHLIGHTED THE CAN
DO SPACE WHERE ELSE PLEASE WAIT
ACNE FASTER WHAT CASE WORKERS
TO. INCREASE ADOPTION
TECHNOLOGY AND A HIGH RATE OF
THE ENGINE ENGINE. AS CHAIR THE
LABOR COMMITTEE WORKER SAFETY
AND JOB QUALITY ON. IMPORTANT
TO ME AND CERTAIN THE COMMITTEE
CALL. I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD BE A TOOL.
THAT BENEFITS WORKERS. I LOOK
FORWARD TO A PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSION GLOBAL POLICEMAN TO
WORKER SAFETY JOB QUALITY AND
WILL GO BOYS IN THESE
INDUSTRIES- AND I'M GRATEFUL
THAT ONE THIS YEAR THIS IS
BEING RECORDED STREAMS OF THE
EVEN FOLKS IN THE CAPITAL. OF
COLLEAGUES AND THEIR STAFFS AND
THOSE IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
WHAT HAVE YOU BOB OPPORTUNITY
HERE AS IN THE WISDOM FROM
THOSE OF THE SHARING WITH US
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO- HAND OVER
THE MIKE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS. OF ANY OPENING COMMENTS
OR- THANK YOU MR CALL. AND
WELCOME TO THE SIXTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TO RIVERSIDE.
AND THANK YOU TO COUNSEL AND
EDWARD. OPENING UP. COUNCIL
CHAMBER- TO US FOR THIS HEARING.
THERE IS PROBABLY NO TOPIC. IT
IS MORE CONTROVERSIAL. THEN THE
TOPIC THE WAREHOUSE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. WHEN I WAS
ELECTED SEVEN YEARS AGO- THE
FORMER MAYOR RON LEVERAGE
CONVENE HERE IN THIS VERY
CHAMBER- A MEETING. TO DISCUSS
WHETHER WAREHOUSE- WORK WOULD
LEAD TO MIDDLE CLASS TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS. AND WE WERE
JOINED- AT THAT TIME BY USC
PROFESSOR ONE A LOT OF. HIS
BOOK IN ONE SHIP REYES SPACE
AND CAPITAL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS VERY INFORMED IF
YOU WERE TO DRIVE FROM RIGHT
HERE- ACROSS THE SIXTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOR MARINO
VALLEY TO PREPARE. YOU WOULD
SEE NOTHING BUT ONE WAREHOUSE
AFTER ANOTHER. BUT WAREHOUSES
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE OUR- ARE A
MATTER OF A FACT AND GOOD FOR
WORST THEY'RE GOING TO REMAIN
WITH. BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT SOME OF THE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF WAREHOUSE. THE TRUCK
TRAFFIC. TO THE AIR POLLUTION
TWO PEOPLE WHO HOUSES- A RIGHT
NEAR. RIGHT ACROSS I ACTUALLY
VISITED ONE HOUSE. IN MARINO
VALLEY. OF THE WAREHOUSE WAS
BUILT RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
FROM THE- SO IF YOU WANT TO
FILL A CHAMBER. WHETHER IT BE-
IN DECEMBER NINETEEN OH IN
MARINO VALLEY OR RIVERSIDE JUST
BRING UP THE TOPIC OF WAREHOUSE
LAST YEAR I WAS ABLE TO GET
LEGISLATION PASSED. AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY THREE. AND WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR IT SAYS
THAT IS CITY. ARE GOING TO USE
TAXPAYER MONEY. TO ENTICE
WAREHOUSES TO COME THERE SHOULD
BE GREATER TRANSPARENCY. AN
EFFORT THAT I THINK WAS A VERY
WORTHWHILE WE'VE WE'VE HEARD
THANK YOU. YOU SEE OUR
PROFESSOR THOMAS PATTERSON.
WROTE THE BOOK EIGHT POINTS TO
WAREHOUSE HISTORICAL POLITICAL
ECONOMY. OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ILLINOIS. AND WE HAVE WITH THIS
THE OP OF THE UC BERKELEY'S.
THE FUTURE WAREHOUSE WORK
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE IN US
JUSTICE INDUSTRY. SO WHETHER IT
IS WORKERS AND WELCOME TO THE
WAREHOUSE WORKERS THAT ARE
HERE. UNION MEMBERS FOR MOTHERS
COME TO SEE ME. LATINO MOTHERS
COME TO VISIT MY OFFICE SPEAK
ME BECAUSE THEY TELL ME. THEY
WANT MORE FOR THEIR CHILDREN
THEN TO BE WAREHOUSE WORK. AND
I AND I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE HERE THAT THE WORK FORCE
IN THE WAREHOUSE INDUSTRY IS BY
AND LARGE LET THE- SO WHAT ARE
THE PLUSES WHETHER THE MINUSES.
FOR THIS REGION. AND FOR THE
INDUSTRY THROUGHOUT. CALIFORNIA
UNITED STATES I THINK THERE'S
SOME OF THE TOPICS THAT WE WILL
DISCUSS TODAY AND I WOULD BE
VERY HAPPY TO SEE IN THE
MORNING. IT IS THE DISCUSSION
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON HERE IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE FOR QUITE
AWHILE IT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT MORE AND HOPEFULLY
THIS. HEARING WILL ADD TO THAT
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU FOR
COMING TO THE HI. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING HERE. THANK
YOU SEVEN THANKS FOR. YES ALL.
THANK YOU I TO WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE. READING THIS HEARING
HERE AS CHAIR OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THOSE HEARINGS TO BE HELD WHAT
THE COMMUNITY AND I JOIN WITH
MY COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEDINA
SAYING THANK YOU FOR SO LONG
THE INLAND EMPIRE. I KNOW IT'S
IN RIVERSIDE BUT I WILL CLEAN
INLAND EMPIRE. THERE ARE SO
MANY ISSUES THAT WE SEE AN END
TO MY DEAR FRIEND HEARING THE
NEWS- COUNCIL NUMBER WE'RE SO
PROUD OF YOU. YEAH I DON'T YEAH
YEAH AND SO LOOKING FORWARD TO
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH A GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I I'VE BEEN
VERY ABOUT WHERE MOST OF
BECAUSE- IT'S THEY HEALTH OF
OUR COMMUNITY THAN MOST
CONCERNED. MY GREATEST CONCERN
I DO WANT THE JOB FOR THOSE WHO
ARE BUILDING A WAREHOUSES DOES
A GREAT JOB AND THEY GET TO
STAY CLOSE TO HOME WELL THEY'RE
BUILDING THE WAREHOUSES. SO
THAT'S WONDERFUL. FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE. IT JUST DOESN'T IT ISN'T
A GOOD THING. WE KNOW THAT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR WORKERS OR
YOUNG MAN- YOU KNOW AND BLANK
OVER 70% WE DO KNOW THAT THE
RATE UNION JOBS IN THE
WAREHOUSES DECREASED OVER THE
YEARS WE KNOW THAT THERE'S AN
INCREASE OF TEMPORARY WORK
HEALTH WORKERS WHEN THAT
HAPPENS THERE ARE LESS BENEFITS
FOR WORKERS. THIS IS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLARS. INDUSTRY AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS. SO MUCH
MONEY TO BE MADE. PEOPLE WERE
MAKING THE MONEY FOR THE OWNERS
SHOULD BE INCREASED THE
BENEFITS FOR THOSE WORKING IN
FOR THOSE WHO ARE TAKING CARE
OF THE WORK. OF THOSE THE ONES
THAT NEED TO. THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES THAT ARE. SUFFERING
THE MOST. WE DO KNOW THAT. THE
IT IS MENTIONED EARLIER THE
READING INJURY SO MUCH HIGHER-
FOR WAREHOUSE WORKERS. THREE
TIMES THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
WHEN YOU'RE WORKING IN A
WAREHOUSE AND FOR THOSE WORKING
IN AMAZON WERE HOUSES EVEN. AND
IT'S JUST AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID
BECAUSE OF THE TIMELINE. WISE
IS LOOKING INTO GETTING
AUTOMATIC NOTICES NOT EVEN
HUMAN CONTACT. THE COMPUTERS
TELLING YOU YOU'RE NOT WORKING
FAST ENOUGH YOU HAVEN'T DONE
ENOUGH BOXES AND NOW YOU NEED
TO STEP IT UP AND THEN YOU'VE
GOT TO GET SENT TO RETRAINING
AND YOU'VE GOT TO KNOW YOU YOU
MIGHT BE FIRED. WITHOUT HUMAN
BEING EVER TALKING TO.
SOMETHING THE WRONG ABOUT THAT.
BUT FOR ME HONESTLY THE BIGGEST
ISSUE THAT I HAVE IS THE HUMAN
IMPACT. KNOWING THAT NOT JUST
ALL WORK IT'S ALSO ALL OF THOSE
AROUND. FOR AMAZON MAYBE IT WAS
VERY VOCAL AND JOIN WITH MANY
LABOR AND- NOT EVERYBODY LABELS
IN THE GREEN. WE STILL LOVE ALL
OF OUR- PEOPLE ALL OF OUR
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY THOSE LABOR.
THE ISRAEL. WE HAVE TO FIND
BETTER WAYS TO THIS IS THE
INDUSTRY'S. IT'S GOING TO BE
FOUND. THEY HAVE TO BE A BETTER
WAY TO. WHETHER YOU TO
ELECTRIFY COMING IN AND THEY'RE
COMING. OR ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING. THOSE WERE
LONG LABOR BUT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING. TO MAKE SURE.
SO THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO FIGHT.
SO NBA. TO WE GET THE FIND
THEMSELVES TO BE ABLE TO GET
THOSE CONTRACTS TO PROVIDE
BENEFITS IN THE END WE OPEN THE
AND- THE MOST RECENT ONE USED
THE STATE'S CARPOOL JUST CENTER.
ALMOST ONE MILLION SQUARE FEET.
WE'RE I AM VERY PROUD OF. THE
GENERAL IDEA OF THE SEVEN. THE
LAWSUIT TO MORE OVERSIGHT. WE
NEED MORE THAN MY COLLEAGUES.
THE WAREHOUSE ACOSTA WE HAVE
THE FAMILY. TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT BILLS IN THE BACKYARD. THE.
ROACHES NOW HAVE YOU. BEEN
DOING. IN THEIR BACKYARD
THERE'S A SENSE BY. JUST WON'T
JUST ONE THERE'S A LOT TO BE
DONE I AM VERY PROUD OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE LEGISLATION
HE INTRODUCED. GOT BY BOTH
HOUSES AND GOT IT SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR- THAT THAT WAS A BIG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
LEARNING SO MUCH MORE THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SO THAT YOU CAN SEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHERE IS. AFTER
HERE THE WE HAVE A- MORE ABOUT
THE ISSUES THAT. AND GEN
DOESN'T SOME OF THE- YOUR
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON SOME OF THE ISSUE.
THE SUPPLY CHAIN THANK. YOU
JUST. WE GOT TOGETHER. TODAY
AND SO. WHEN I HAVE. THE FIRST
ONE. THIS YEAR IS OVER HI GENE.
AND THE SECOND. AND SO THEN YOU
START BY. ONE TIME PANEL. TAKE
OVER. PANEL THE- QUESTION THE
BILL HANDLES OR WILL BE NOT TO
FOR PUBLIC HE DOES HAVE A
COMMENT. SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME FIRST. WILL PROVIDE
THAT. WITH US TODAY MICHAEL.
THIS IS THE BEST ACTIVE RESERVE.
MICHAEL BASIS THE BEST ECONOMIC.
I OR SIDE. I WOULD BE THE BEST
A SOCIOLOGY EACH YEAR LABOR
STUDIES AT THE OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE GOOD TO HAVE LOCAL
ACADEMIC YEAR OF THAT. IS
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF ILLINOIS
CHICAGO. PROBABLY GRAY THAT SHE
CAME ALL THE WAY HERE FROM
CHICAGO WHEN SHE HEARD ABOUT.
DISCUSSING SHARE TIME WITH SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES THAT SHARE
BECAUSE HE OF THE WAREHOUSE
WORKER RESOURCE CENTER. AND
THEN THE FORGET OF TEAMSTERS
LOCAL NINETY THIRTY TWO I
BELIEVE. TO YOU ARE BEST
SUITABLE PRESENT JOINT LEAD.
EIGHT MINUTES. ALSO. YEAH SO
BUSTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR- THE KIND INTRODUCTION-
MICHAEL BASS FISHING SOME OF
OUR- OUR STATE OF. REPORT ON
THE HIGHER. DEVELOPING RESEARCH.
ALL THE WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT THE UNEMPLOYMENT RECOVERY
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
IMPRESSIVE. GAINES OUTPACING
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
COUNTRY AS A WHOLE THIS IS BEEN
SPURRED BY- JOB GROWTH IN BOTH
SIDES AND BRING YOUR COUNTY-
THAT ABOUT A STROKE- AND THE
REST OF CALIFORNIA. STILL YOU
WONDER ABOUT WHAT THE QUALITY
OF THE JOBS ARE- AS WORKERS IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE LESS ACCESS
TO FULL TIME FOR YOUR JOB- AND
ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
EMPLOYER PROVIDED HEALTH
INSURANCE. AND IN GENERAL
WORKERS IN THE IN THE IN THE
EMPIRE. I TO BREAKING NUMBERS
TO THEIR- OVERALL 38% OF
WORKERS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE-
MAKE. THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR ABOVE ALL THAT
NUMBER COMES FROM- A LIVING
WAGE STANDARD- PROVIDE BY
REPORTS OUT OF AND I. ALSO AS
YOU CAN SEE- DIFFERENTIALS IN
THIS GOOD JOB RATE- LARGE WHEN
WE CONSIDER- GENDER AS WELL AS
WITH THE- NOW WHY IS NOT THE
CASE- WE LOOK AT THE TOP FIVE-
PULLING INDUSTRY. AND I'M
HIGHER. THEN WE TAKE FIVE TO
MAY TAKE AWAY FROM THIS. THE
FIRST IS WITHIN EACH OF THOSE
FIVE INDUSTRIES WORKERS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE MAKE LESS THAN
THE STATE AVERAGE OR FOR IT IN
THE- LAST SEVEN CALIFORNIA-
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE
TRANSPORTATION AND WAREHOUSING.
ALL OF THIS MAKES 28% LAST. ALL
THE WORKERS- WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY THE REST OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE SECOND BIG TAKE
AWAY FROM THIS IS THAT ALL FIVE
INDUSTRIES. ARE RELATIVELY LOW
PAYING AND THAT THEY PAY LESS
THAN THE STATE AVERAGE- IN
MONTHLY OVERALL. SO THERE'S-
WERE OVER REPRESENTED IN
LOOKING INDUSTRIES- AND WE ARE
UNDER- REPRESENTED IN HIGHER.
THE PLACES WHERE THE MOST
DRAMATIC OR PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTIFIC TECHNIQUE TECHNICAL
JOBS OF FINANCE AND INSURANCE
AND INFORMATION SERVICE. IN OUR
FUTURE WORK THAT WE'RE WE'RE
CURRENTLY DEVELOPING WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT- THAT JOB
GROWTH AND WHAT KINDS OF JOBS-
THOSE ARE TO TAKE DEFINITIONS
OF JOBS- PROVIDE BY THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTION BUT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE JOB. ALL
THAT LEAD TO THOSE GOOD JOBS.
AND ALL OTHER CASES WE'RE GOING
TO CONSIDER THIS SEPARATELY-
BASED ON WHETHER OR NOT- CALLS
TO RESERVE FIVE FOR THE FOR THE
JOB. TO WONDER WHAT ARE THEY
INDUSTRY ALL THAT EVERYBODY'S
JOB AND WHAT IS HAPPENING. IN
INDUSTRIES AND ALSO OCCUPATION
OVER TIME. SO THIS NEXT FIGURE
IS SHOWING IMPLEMENT SHARE FOR
ABOUT FIFTEEN INDUSTRY WITH THE
MOST GOOD. JOBS IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. THE BIG TAKEAWAY HERE
IS THAT THE INDUSTRIES AND RIDE
OUR JOB WITH INFORMATION SHARED
ON GROWING. AND THE JOB FOR THE
IN ON OTHER ENVELOPE THAT THE
DIAGONAL LINE OF THE INDUSTRIES
IN WHICH- IN CONSIDERATION SO-
IN TRANSPORTATION THE PROVIDE A
LOT OF THE JOB- ABOUT. TO BE
GROWING AND IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE MANY BACKING
TRADITIONALLY HAS PROVIDED MANY
GOOD JOB AND THEY STILL DO ALL
OF THE EMPLOYMENT YEAR. THE
LAST DECADE. SIMILARLY WE DO
THAT. THE EXERCISE MY- THE
OCCUPATION IN WHICH THAT ARE
PROVIDING A LOT OF GOOD JOBS
AND ACCESSIBLE JOBS. THAT ARE
GROWING. IN INSTALLATION
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THE JOBS- THAT ARE
TREATING LARGE SUPERVISOR
POSITION I'M NOT RUNNING FOR
THE- MANY INDUSTRY- REALLY
REMOVING FROM THE LADDER OF JOB
WORKERS WITHOUT. I THINK THE
REST OF MY- OVER THE PHONE WITH.
IN THE- FIRE. YEAH ENTRY LEVEL
OF BLUE COLLAR WAREHOUSE
WORKERS. WAREHOUSE ASSOCIATES
ARE IN ABOUT FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR PLUS BENEFITS BUT THIS IS
NOT ENOUGH- GIVEN THE HIGH COST
OF LIVING IS SPECIALLY TO
SUPPORT A FAMILY- CONSISTENT
WITH THAT THE ECONOMIC ROUND
TABLE HAS JUST ISSUED A REPORT
A VERY GOOD ONE- KNOWN AS TOO
BIG TO GOVERN. IT FOUND THAT
MOST AMAZON WAREHOUSE WORKERS
WERE STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY
THEY FOUND THAT TIME FULL YEAR
WAREHOUSE WORKER. AVERAGE OF
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE END OF IT MOST OF THIS WAS
IN MEDICAID AND MANY OF THESE.
WORKERS COULD NOT AFFORD IT THE
HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN OFFERED
BY AMAZON FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
OF 57% OF THESE WORKERS OF FULL
TIME FULL YEAR WAREHOUSE
WORKERS WERE LIVING IN
OVERCROWDED AND SUB STANDARD
HOUSING. MORE CLOSELY AT OF THE
CONDITIONS FOR AMAZON WAREHOUSE
WORKERS IN A WORK WITH A TEAM
OF RESEARCHERS AT UC RIVERSIDE
TO COLLECT INTERVIEWS FROM
FORTY FOUR FORMER AND YOU MOVE
ON WE'RE HOUSE. FOR AND THEY
HAD A LOT OF STORIES ABOUT THE-
JOB QUALITY OF MANY OF THESE
WORKERS WERE WE THE SEASONAL
WORKERS TURNOVER WAS VERY VERY
HIGH. WORK A REPORTER WAS
PHYSICALLY GRUELING AND
EXHAUSTING THE WORKS JUST FOR
VERY LONG FOR FULL TIME WORKERS.
NEARLY ALL OF THEM AGREED THAT
THEY WERE HE OR EXHAUSTION BY
THE END OF THEIR WORK IN THESE
WORKS AT. THE LAST HOURS AT THE
MINIMUM USUALLY MORE RIGHT IF
THERE'S HIGHER CUSTOMER DEMAND
THEY'RE ASKED TO WORK OVERTIME.
AND IS A VERY HARD FOR WORKERS
TO COMBINE ESPECIALLY FOR
COLLEGE. STUDENTS THAT ARE
TRYING TO GET A DEGREE YOU GET
A BETTER JOB. WERE FOR THOSE
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN OR OR
TAKING CARE OF AND THEN THERE
ALSO PRESSURED TO WORK VERY
VERY FAST- PRESSURE TO MAKE
RATE. THESE DAYS IN THE IN THE
AMAZON WAREHOUSES OR FACE
TERMINATION THIS IS. VERY VERY
STRESSFUL IN THIS ALSO PUT
PRESSURE ON THEM. TO NOT FOLLOW
THE SAFETY PROCEDURES RIGHT
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T. THEY
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THE RATE OR
THEY MIGHT GET. FROM THESE WORK
RATES ARE REALLY REALLY
STRINGENT VERY HIGH AND THEY
OFTEN SEEM TO BE GOING UP. THEY
ARE ALSO BEING- SURVEILLED
ELECTRONICALLY IN TERMS OF NOT
JUST THEIR WORK RATE FOR THEIR
ERROR RATE. TIME ON. TASK ALL.
YEAH THIS PRESSURE ON THEM NOT
TO USE THE BATHROOM NOT TO
FOLLOW SAFETY PROCEDURES. SO
THIS IS TAKING A REAL HOLE
RIGHT ON TOP OF THE FACT THAT
THE WORK BREAKS ARE OFTEN
INSUFFICIENT GIVEN THE SIZE OF
THE FACILITIES AND HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO GET. THE BREAK ROOM OR
THE REST. RIGHT WITH THIS I
WOULD DEAL HAD AN INVESTIGATIVE
REPORT THAT FOUND THAT IT WAS
ON INJURY RATES OR EVEN HIGHER
THAN THE INDUSTRY AVERAGE RATE
OF ABOUT ONE OUT OF EVERY TEN
FULL TIME IT WAS A WORKERS- HAS.
INJURY IN THE EVEN HIGHER IN
THE AUTOMATED WE'RE HOUSES.
SUCH AS THE ONE EASY FAIL THERE
THE RATES. EVEN HIGHER WITH
SEVENTEEN. SIX HUNDRED WORKERS
WERE WERE ANYTHING INJURY. WHAT
IS A BRING SOME OF THE VOICES
OF AMAZON WAREHOUSE WORKERS
INTO THE ROOM- SO THESE ARE ALL
FROM FORMER FAMILIES ON WORKERS
THEY WERE WORKING AS WERE
HEALTH WORKERS WAS THAT I WAS
ALWAYS SCARED EVERY DAY BECAUSE
I WASN'T MAKING. REYES ANOTHER
TOLD AS THE RATES ARE JUST TOO
DEMANDING AN ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
AT TIMES AND IT'S A VERY
STRESSFUL THE WORKERS. THERE'S
EVEN BIG PIECES DOCUMENTED FOR
PEOPLE TRIED TO COMMIT SUICIDE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT MEETING THE
RATE IN THE FEAR LOSING THEIR
JOB AT AMAZON BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND EFFECTIVE NEWSWEEK RIGHT.
HELLO CORD ABOUT. SUICIDE.
THERE WAS ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF WHAT WORK
REPORTED IT IT WAS A LITTLE TOO
MUCH FOR ME PHYSICALLY I HAD
BRUISES ALL OVER MY LEGS
BECAUSE OF THE BOXES I WAS
THROWING AROUND ANOTHER
REPORTED I ONLY WORKED THERE
FOR THREE MONTHS AND I WAS
ALREADY HAVING BACK PROBLEMS
WITH THAT I WAS TWENTY YEARS
OLD AND I HAD BACK PROBLEMS
THAT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN HE WAS
NOT ALONE IN THE WORKPLACE
REPORTING BACK INJURIES WE ALSO
HEARD ABOUT REPETITIVE MOTION
INJURIES AND- SEVERAL THE- WE
REPORTED HAVING. THE LOUD
CHEERING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THE. YEAH. THANKS SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME REALLY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE- WHAT I
PRESENTED A NEW RESEARCH FROM
MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE. FOR
YOU. BASED ON EXTENSIVE
INTERVIEWS THAT WE DID WITH
THEIR HOUSE OPERATORS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ABOUT THE PLAN- FOR
THE MEETING. NEW TECHNOLOGIES
IN THEIR WAREHOUSE. TECHNOLOGY.
THE TECHNOLOGY OF WHAT DO THEIR
JOB MORE EASILY BETTER SOON
WAREHOUSES THE INCREASING USE
OF TECHNOLOGY REPRESENTS A WIN
FOR EVERYONE COULD MANUAL JOB
YOU NEED BETTER FIRMS ACHIEVE
MORE EFFICIENCY COULD CUSTOMERS
BENEFIT. SO THE MAIN QUESTION
OF THIS RESEARCH WHAT DOES THE-
TECHNOLOGY REPRESENTS. ANY SORT
THE ANSWER IS NOT WITHOUT. OUR
RESEARCH FOUND THAT OVER THE
NEXT DECADE JOB QUALITY IS
LIKELY TO CHANGE AND COULD
BECOME SIGNIFICANTLY MORE. IN
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE JOB
QUALITY IS A BIGGER ISSUE THAN
JOB LONG. RIGHT THIS AREA ABOUT.
THE MOST LIKELY SCENARIO FOR
MOST FACILITIES IS NOT ALONE
AUTOMATION PARTIAL AUTOMATION
AND LABOR AUGMENTATION WITH
POTENTIAL NEGATIVE EFFECT ON
JOBS. SO RATHER THAN WIDESPREAD
AUTOMATION IN THE NEAR TERM AND
WE'RE TALKING THE NEXT DECADE.
THIS IS IN THE PIECE OF WORK
PROCESS AND DISTILLING JOBS. IN
NEW FORMS OF SURVEILLANCE AND
MANAGEMENT VOICE UNDERMINE
LOOKING. THAT'S THE NEXT
WORKERS WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
THE WORK FORCE IN CALIFORNIA
WILL DISPROPORTIONATELY BEAR
THE BRUNT OF THE CHANGE. AND
THE LEADING EDGE IS DRIVEN BY.
AND ECONOMY AND AMAZON IS
PLAYING A SUBSTANTIAL IN
REMAKING THE COMPETITIVE
DYNAMICS. WE'RE HOUSING
INDUSTRY EMPLOYS ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DIRECT HIRE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THIS IS A BAD
UNDER ESTIMATE GIVEN THE-
TEMPORARY. NEARLY HALF OF THOSE
WORKERS ARE HERE IN THE
RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARDINO
ONTARIO MSA MAJORITY WAREHOUSE
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
NIXON BLACK. IS THE FRONTLINE
WORKERS IN LARGELY MANUAL LABOR
JOBS. WANT TO GET TO THE- YES
THIS CHART IS IMPORTANT-
RESEARCH SHOWS EMPLOYMENT IN
RED AND WE JUST MOVED IN
200-012-2018 THE THING TO NOTE
HERE IS THAT INFLATION ADJUSTED
WAGES IN THE INDUSTRY HAVE
ACTUALLY FALLEN TWO THOUSAND
ONE IT'S OTHER MOST RAPID
DECLINE IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
AT THE SAME TIME EMPLOYMENT
ROSE SHARPLY THIS IS COUNTER
INTUITIVE. ARE AT WHEN
EMPLOYMENT DEMAND RISES CLASSIC
ECONOMIC MODELS PREDICT THAT
WAGES WILL RISE TO THE TAKE
AWAY IN WAREHOUSING IS THAT WE
JUST HAS STAGNATED FOR NEARLY
TWO DECADES THEY'RE FALLING NOW
AND THEY ARE THE LOWEST POINT.
TWO THOUSAND ONE. WHEN HOUSING
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
EFFICIENT OPERATION OF THE
PRODUCTION AND CONSUMPTION SO
SUPPLY AND DEMAND. NEEDS IN A
WAREHOUSE IT'S A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF FIRMS COMPETITIVE
STRATEGIES. BUT IT'S BEEN A
LAGGARD IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL ADOPTION FOR A
FEW REASONS. ONE VERY NARROW
MARGIN NEED THAT THE INDUSTRY
IS HIGHLY COST SENSITIVE. THIS
BAND FINANCIAL CONSERVATISM
RESULT IN RISK OF VERSION FOUR
FIRMS TRY TO AVOID TAKING ON
RISK FOR SHIFTED TO ON TO OTHER
COMPANIES. LIKE SUBCONTRACTORS
AND TEMP AGENCIES. AND BECAUSE
OF THIS OUTSOURCING IS A
PREVALENT PRACTICING WAREHOUSE.
OUTSOURCING DYNAMICS HAVE
TENDED TO SLOW THE PROCESS OF
INNOVATION. FINALLY THE
INDUSTRIES IS IN THE MIDST OF A
PEOPLE ROBBED BY YOU COMMERCE.
WHICH INTRODUCES NEW DYNAMICS
INTO WAREHOUSE PROPHECIES. ON
THE ONE HAND YOU HAVE A VERY
LABOR INTENSIVE PROCESS OF
ASSEMBLING BE COMMERCE
SUPPORTERS. AND ON THE OTHER
HAND YOU HAVE ROOMS COMPETING
WITH AMAZON'S ABILITY TO
DELIVER QUICKLY WHICH IS SHAPED
CONSUMER EXPECTATIONS CROSS THE
BORDER. AMAZON IS HAVING
WIDESPREAD EFFECT ACROSS THE
RETAIL AND LOGISTICS SECTORS.
WE'RE HEADING TOWARD CHANGES IN
THE QUALITY OF JOBS IN
WAREHOUSES FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE LIKELY TO SEE WORK
INTENSIFICATION. ROSE WITH HIS
HEART ON BODIES AS WE'VE HEARD.
THAT THAT THERE'S A POTENTIAL
TO THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO
REDUCE- THE MOST ARDUOUS
ACTIVITIES LIKE TWISTING AND
LIFTING. HOWEVER OUR RESEARCH
FOUND THAT THOSE GAINS MAY BE
CANCELED OUT. INCREASES IN
WORKLOAD AND PIECE OF WORK. ONE
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS A HANGING
BAG OVER. EACH BAG HOLDS
TOGETHER KIND OF ITEM IS
DELIVERED TO WORK STATION YOU
SEE HERE THE WORKERS. THIS IS
THE RULES WALKING AND CAN
REDUCE EXPOSURE TO OTHER ORGANS
ARE GOING ON THE WRIST. BUT IT
ALSO SERVES TO CLOSELY TRACK
THE PRODUCTIVITY OF WORKERS AND
PIECES THEIR WORK I CONSTANTLY
DELIVERING PACKAGES TO THE
WORKER ADDED TO FIND ME. THE
SECOND CHANGE IS DE SKILLING
WHICH IS THE PROCESS OF
BREAKING UP A JOB INTO SMALLER
TASKS. AND FIGURING OUT WHICH
ACTIVITIES TO SIMPLIFY SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY. WE NEED TO PROVIDE
TASK TO EXPAND THE POTENTIAL
WORKFORCE FOR EXAMPLE YOU MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HIRE TEMPORARY
WORKERS BECAUSE YOU REMOVE THE
NEED FOR ANY FAMILIARITY WITH
THE WAREHOUSE. IT ALSO SHORTENS
TRAINING TIME AND REDUCES YOUR
TURN OVER FIVE. DIFFERENT
PLAYERS IT'S A WIN. FOR WORKERS
IT COULD MEAN LOWER WAGES AND
MORE CHURNING THROUGH TEMPORARY
JOB. AN EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THAT
FOLLOW ME ON A MOBILE ROBOT
SHOWN HERE. IT LEADS WORKERS
ACROSS THE WAREHOUSE FACING
THEM AS THEY WALK AND PICK
BORDERS IT SIMPLIFIES THE ORDER
OF SELECTION PROCESS. THE
SYSTEM REMOVES ALL DECISION
MAKING BY THE WORKERS AND SET
THE WATER SPEED AND ROUTE. BY
SIMPLIFYING THE PROCESS ANY
PLAYER COULD BRING SOMEONE IN
OFF THE STREET VIRTUALLY TETHER
THEM TO THIS CARD. IN A WAY
THEY- THE FINAL BUDGET OF
CHANGE IS SURVEILLANCE AN
ALGORITHMIC MANAGEMENT. I WOULD
MAKE MANAGEMENT INTRODUCES NEW
FORMS OF WORKPLACE CONTROL
WHERE THE REGULATION OF WITH
THIS PERFORMANCE IS GRANULAR.
SCALABLE AND POTENTIALLY
REMEMBER. THIS IS NEW I
VISIBILITY TO MONITOR WITH THIS
PRECISE MOVEMENTS AT DALY
SOMETHING'S NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO
BEFORE. THERE'S VERY LITTLE
TRANSPARENCY INTO WHAT DATA IS
BEING COLLECTED FOR WHAT
PURPOSE AND HOW IT'S BEING USED
AND STORED. AND THERE'S NO
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE SOFTWARE
RULES THAT ARE MANAGING AND
GOVERNING WORK PLACES. THERE
ARE NUMBER OF POTENTIAL ON
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
COULD RESULT SMALL. EMPLOYEE
MORALE COULD BE DAMAGED. TURN
OVER FIFTY INCREASE OVER WORK
AND BURN OUT. THE MOST ALARMING
ARE THE POTENTIAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY IMPACT. THE WORKERS ARE
AT AN ELEVATED RISK OF INJURY
BUT WHEN YOU ADD INCREASED
WORKLOAD AND SPEED UP TO THE
MIX. ATTENTION FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY RISK INCREASE. THE LONG
TERM PHYSICAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
IMPACT. ARE VERY POORLY
UNDERSTOOD. TECHNOLOGY IN THAT
ARE INHERENTLY GOOD OR BAD
HUMANS CREATE TECHNOLOGY WE
BAKE OUR BIASES IN ON THE FRONT
HAND AND WE MAKE CHOICES ABOUT
HOW TO GET IMPLEMENTED ON THE
BACK AND NONE OF THIS IS. PRE
DETERMINED. WHAT THE VOICE
REGULATION AND VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION NEW HEALTH AND SAFETY
WITH. WITH OUR VITAL IN SHAPING
THE PATH OF TECHNOLOGICAL
CHANGE. WAREHOUSE OPERATOR
STAND TO GAIN SUBSTANTIALLY THE
NEW TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES THE
QUESTION IS HOW THESE GAMES
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED. AND WE
HAVE TO START NOW TO WHAT A WIN
LOSE PROPOSITION FOR SHORT TERM
BENEFITS CAPTION BY THE
INDUSTRY IN THE LONG RUN COSTS
ARE BORNE BY WORKERS IN THE-
THANK. THANK YOU DOCTOR. NEXT
UP. DOES THE WAREHOUSE WORKERS
OR- GOOD MORNING- THANK YOU
HAVE FOR HAVING US HERE I'M
SURE SHE ON THE DRUG FOR THE
WAREHOUSE WITH RESOURCE CENTER
WORK ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING JOBS IN THE- REGION.
WHAT WE DO IS WE DO EDUCATION
ADVOCACY ACTION WE SUPPORTED.
WORKERS WHO'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH ISSUES INCLUDING WAY STUFF
SO WE SUPPORT WORKERS. TO
COLLECT OVER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN LOST WAGES OF THE
LAST. SEVEN YEARS- WE DEAL A
LOT WITH WORKERS SIMPLICITY
STAFFING AGENCIES OR HAVE
CONTINUED IN SHORT TERM
EMPLOYMENT. THE HUGE PROBLEM
WAREHOUSE SECTOR. SO GAGE
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS TO. TAKE
ACTION THE WORKPLACE TO DEMAND-
FULL TIME- FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT
FROM IMPLEMENT. IT WILL DO A
LOT OF WORK RUN HEALTH AND
SAFETY- WORK WITH CAL OSHA AND
OTHER AGENCIES TO- GET
SITUATION COVERING OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND WORKERS TO. CONDITIONS.
IN THERE WHILE. YEAH BE NO
RIVERSIDE LA COUNTY SO I SHOULD
TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT WHAT WE
SEE IN THE IN THE NONUNION
SECTOR OF THE WAREHOUSE
INDUSTRY BUT I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU IS. GIVE YOU A LITTLE US
RESEARCH THAT DONE ON THIS IN
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS SO THE
FEW. OF THE REFERRING TO ONE IS
REPORT THAT SHE CANNOT THEY
NATIONAL ROB LOVE. TOGETHER
TIME FOR THIS PANEL THEY'RE
DOING SOME ON JOURNAL. AND TELL
YOU ABOUT THAT IT'S A HUGE
ISSUE THAT. NOT ONLY ARE THE-
IN THIS INDUSTRY. BUT THERE'S
HIGH TURNOVER BECAUSE- WORKERS
ARE ABLE TO KEEP UP FOR.
WORKERS FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT THE
KIND OF JOB THEY WANT. TO SO
THE REPORTS. YEAH AND TURN OVER
OR AT THE- IN. YET NOT A GROUND
TO IN LOS ANGELES GIVE A LAST.
TO THE TO THE TO GOVERN. THE
DIG INTO AN- OF PRESS. INCIDENT
LA OR- RIVERSIDE ASSEMBLY OKAY.
AND THEN BEING A COALITION THE
NETWORK OF ORGANIZATIONS AROUND
THE COUNTRY TAKING ACTION
AMAZON. FOR LAST YEAR THAT
FISHERIES MENTION THAT LOOKS
INTO THE- LOT OF. WITH THIS A
COLLECTED UP LOT FROM OSHA THAT
LOOK AT THE RATE THAT WAS ON
THE COMPUTER THE- RIGHT IN THE
WAREHOUSE INDUSTRY WELL AND IN
THE- SO JUST TO DIG IN A LITTLE
BIT ON SOME THE DETAILS ABOUT
WHAT THE INDUSTRY LOOKS LIKE-
FILL IN A LITTLE BIT. OF
CONTEXT. SO WITH THE MAJOR
EMPLOYER THROUGH THE MAJOR
EMPLOYMENT- CATEGORIES OR JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS AND
WAREHOUSING. ARE JUST AFFRONT
OPERATOR FOR THE DRIVERS-
CALIFORNIA- SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
OF THEM. AND WILL BE MEAN WAGE
THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS. THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR- LABOR.
THIS BY HAND DO A LOT OF THE
PACKAGING EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE- STATEWIDE AVERAGE AGE
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND FACTORS IMPACT BY HAND OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND ON
270-008-0080 DOLLARS PER YEAR-
SO THAT'S WHAT WE SEE IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. SIXTEEN YEARS
LABOR- AND YOU KNOW GET A HUGE
PERCENTAGE. OF PROBABLY CLOSE
TO HALF ARGUING IN THE ENTIRE-
IN THIS EMPLOYEE INCLUDES
WORKERS ABOUT THE STAFFING
AGENCIES IN PEOPLE. IT'S HARD
TO BUT WE ESTIMATED SOMEWHERE
AROUND THIRTY THIRTY FIVE.
EMPLOYEE YEAH TWO FOUR UNDER
THE SAME CONDITIONS IT WAS ON
THE DOCKING AGENCIES. THE TO
YOU AS IF YOU'RE RIGHT YOU KNOW.
SO THIS THIS ASIDE FROM THE
ECONOMIC ROUND TABLES RESEARCH-
AGAIN JUST CONTACT. THE LIVING
WAGE FOR OUR REGION IS- THIRTY
FOR TO FOR THEM TO WORKING WITH
ALL THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR EACH OF. SO
YES SEVEN FOUR THOUSAND. THAT'S
WHAT YOU WOULD NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A LIVING WAGE.
EXAMINING THE COUNTY. IT'S NOT
WE SEE MORE AND YOU LA OR THE
BAY AREA STILL. REALLY HIGH AND
RISING VERY QUICKLY. IN AGAIN
GOOD ACTORS WHICH IS THAT WE
SAW. ON THE PREVIOUS PAGE. THAT
WAS IT'S NOT THE WAYS THAT WE
SAW THERE DO NOT MATCH UP AND
THAT'S THE WAY. AS WE SAID THAT
WE DO A LOT OF THE WORKERS OF
HAVING TO DEPEND ON STATE
SUBSIDIES AND ON PUBLIC
BENEFITS AGAIN THERE'S NOTHING
SHAMEFUL ABOUT RECEIVING
BENEFITS SWITCHING FOR THE
PLAYERS THAT REFUSE TO PROVIDE-
A LIVING WAGE AND BENEFITS TO
THEIR WORKERS. THEY KNOW WHO
THE BENEFIT FROM. SO YOU KNOW
THE AVERAGE FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE
JUST FOR MEMBERS ON WORKERS YOU
SEE TWENTY FOUR CENTS. FROM
PUBLIC BENEFITS TO PAY FOR THE.
FOR A SECOND YOU EMPHASIZE
WHILE WORKING ON AMAZON. AMAZON
IS NOW THE BIGGEST PRIVATE
EMPLOYER IN THE INLAND EMPIRE-
WELL OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
WORKERS IN THE REGION. TEN
YEARS AGO THERE WEREN'T ANY
AMAZON WAREHOUSE ISSUE AT ALL
RIGHT THE FIRST ONE OF THESE
NUMBER. ELEVEN IT'S A LESS THAN
A DECADE YOUR RISEN UP TO
BECOME THE LARGEST IN ALSO
WITHOUT GOING IN OUR AREA NOW
THE SECOND LARGEST EMPLOYER.
COUNTRY IN ABOUT THE- FOURTEEN
MAJOR AS IN THE AREA- EACH OF
WHICH WAS SOMEWHERE BETWEEN ONE
AND FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE IN OUR
FOCUS IS THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
DOMINANT PLAYER BUT THEY'RE
ALSO THE FIRST MOVE THEY'RE THE
ONES WHO WOULD MEAN A LOT OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES. I WOULD.
MANAGEMENT STANDARDS- THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO ARE REALLY. TRYING
THREE THAT RIGHT THE JUST IN
TIME TO OUR DELIVERY. PACKAGE
THAT YOU RECEIVE. EASY COME SO
FAST IS RELATED RELATED
DIRECTLY TO THE CASE OF WORKING
AROUND THE BASE OF THE DELIVERY
GUY YOU HAVE. TO A DAY
CORRELATED AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
SOURCES OF THAT. BUT A LITTLE
BIT TO THIS ISSUE OF TURNOVER
WHICH CAME OUT IN THIS REPORT.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW THE COPY.
RIGHT NOW- THE TURNOVER RATE IN
SAN MARINO RIVERSIDE COUNTIES
IN WAREHOUSING. ARE NOW CLOSE
TO OR OVER A HUNDRED PERCENT.
PER YEAR. SO PEOPLE ARE STAYING
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR- IN WHAT
WE SEE THIS IS FOR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. BUT THIS IS RAPIDLY
INCREASING SO WAREHOUSE
INDUSTRY- IF YOU LOOK AT THE
BOTTOM IT SAYS EIGHTY TWO
PERCENT. TURNOVER RATE.
CALIFORNIA IN THE WAREHOUSE
INDUSTRY. PRIVATE INDUSTRY IT'S
JUST UNDER SEVENTY. SO THAT THE
TURNOVER RATE IS ALREADY HIRED
IN THE WAREHOUSES. AND THEN
WE'LL SEE THIS CHART SHOWS THE
INCREASE AS AMAZON'S BECOME THE
DOMINANT PLAYER IN WAREHOUSES
AND THE BIGGEST PRIVATE
EMPLOYER REGION ESPECIALLY
WAREHOUSING. THE TURNOVER RATE.
SO WHAT WE SAW WAS AROUND TWO
THOUSAND NINE. ELEVEN BEFORE.
IN THIS REGION THE TURNOVER
RATE THESE WAREHOUSES WAS 6065%
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS SINCE
THEN IT'S GONE UP TO CLOSE TO
HOME. THE EMAIL SUPPORT
ACTUALLY DONE A COUPLE OF
COUNTIES- OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY WHERE THERE'S ONLY AN
AMAZON WAREHOUSE SO WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE TURNOVER RATE
IS THERE. 192% SO EVERY SIX
MONTHS THE- WHY IS THAT THEY
PAY FIFTY DOLLARS AN HOUR RIGHT
WILL THE BENEFITS WILL BE CLICK
OVER BETTER THAN WHAT THE YOU
KNOW THE AVERAGE MINIMUM WAGE
JOB IS. BECAUSE OF THE CASE
BECAUSE OF THE RATE BECAUSE OF
THE INJURY RATES- PEOPLE FROM
OTHER VERY VERY QUICKLY SO IT'S
NOT WRITING A STABLE. SOURCE OF
JOBS. DESPITE ALL NO. AND THEN.
THE INJURY SIDE THE OTHER SIDE
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE HAVE HIGH
YOU KNOW HIGH TURNOVER HIGH
RATES OF WORK- ON THE INJURY
RATED AMAZON AGAIN THIS IS FROM
THE PACKAGING. A LOT OF. TV
RATINGS ON THREE TIMES
NATIONALLY- BUT- SO AND IT'S
WELL OVER TWICE AS MUCH AS IT
IS FOR THE AVERAGE WAREHOUSE SO
WHERE HOUSING IS ALREADY
DEFINED BY CAL OSHA AND THE
HIGH HAZARD INDUSTRY. AND YOU
KNOW THEN ANIMALS ON THEIR LIVE
SHOW THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY HAVE
ONE. I REALLY ENJOY THE- SO.
YOU CAN. THAT ALRIGHT BACK TO
WORK. THE WORKERS ARE MOVING
VERY. KEEP UP ON THE NOT DOING.
SO THESE INJURIES ARE SPRAINS
STRAINS AND CHAIRS WHICH AGAIN
INDICATES OR CONTUSIONS
INDICATES THAT COMES FROM
MOVING VERY QUICKLY NOT
NECESSARILY. WHAT THE REALLY
STUFF RELATED TO TWO MACHINES
IT'S A FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE
JUST. SO OUR ANALYSIS IS THAT
THERE NEED TO BE- STRESS ON THE
WORKING TOGETHER TO TAKE ACTION
TO IMPROVE THEIR CONDITIONS BUT
ALSO. POLICY FROM YOUR- THANK
YOU SO MUCH. FINAL. EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR NOT ONLY THE
PANELISTS BUT THE ELECTED
LEADERSHIP TO BRING AWARENESS
THAT I'VE- PERSONALLY FOUGHT
FOR TWENTY YEARS. THANK YOU. SO.
NINETEEN NINETY. I WAS A
WAREHOUSE. TWO CASES. I MADE
MORE MONEY STARTING OUT
EIGHTEEN. START THIRTY YEARS
LATER THAT. SHOP I DON'T EITHER
I DON'T A LOT OF THAT STUFF.
THAT AS A WAREHOUSE I STILL SEE
MYSELF AS A WAREHOUSE. MAKE MY
WAY ABOUT. I JUST I DON'T KNOW
HOW I MEAN I CAN SEE OR TELL
YOU WHY I THINK IT'S OUT OF THE
HOUSE IN. THE REALITY OF.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS IN THIS REGION.
SITUATION GOT A- PAY ATTENTION
WE PUT THAT IN CONTEXT IN
NINETEEN NINETY. I WAS
SOMETHING THIRTY YEARS LATER
THAT'S NOT TAKING PLACE ANOTHER
DOLLAR WHAT I WAS MAKING
NINETEEN NINETIES MORE THAN
WHAT THEY WERE. MY STARTING
WAGES. THIS MORNING WITH THE
START. THAT IS SO IMPACTFUL TO
BE REALLY DISCUSS. SOME OF THE
COVER NUMBER THERE ISN'T
COVERED ORGANIZING AIR. EFFORTS
IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS IN
THIS AREA THE STATE. TRAVEL
I'VE HAD A- PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF WORKERS IN THIS REGION HELP
ORGANIZE OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS MANY OF THEM THOUSANDS OF
THE- WAREHOUSE. TIME OPERATIONS
WHICH YOU'RE SPEAKING OF. WE
SUCCESSFULLY ORGANIZED. IT'S A
DROP IN THE BUCKET WHAT
EVERYBODY DOES. ALSO I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE STRUGGLES. NO NO
WAY OUT POINTED OUT OF THAT
HAPPENING IN THIS INDUSTRY
ALLOWED TO HAVE HAPPEN INDUSTRY
MAKES IT RATHER DIFFICULT FOR
ORGANIZED I REMEMBER. GOING ON
TOUR WITH THE HIGH RANKING
ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND SOMEBODY
SAID OLD WAREHOUSE JOBS ARE
JUST JOBS. THEY ACTUALLY WORK
MOST PEOPLE ARE. AT THE HIGHER.
OBVIOUSLY DEPENDING ON. THE BIG
DIFFERENCE. BUT THE REALITY IS
A LOT OF PEOPLE YOU THOSE JOBS
AS WELL THEY'RE JUST. GOING TO
BE THE- SHORT TERM THE REALITY
IS THERE AT THAT LOCATION. IN A
MOVING TO ANOTHER LOCATION
LOCATION LOCATION. AND THEY'RE
SPENDING YEARS IF NOT DECADES A
MOVIE JOB A JOB THAT IS
DEFINITELY A STRUGGLE OF
WORKERS AND THE STRUGGLE FOR
THE ORDER. IS IF THE- IF
EVERYBODY'S MOVING AROUND LIKE
THEY ARE BY DESIGN MY- BY
DESIGN BY THE DEVELOP. I FOR
SYSTEMS BEEN DEVELOP VERY HARD
STICK TO THEIR POINT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY FIND SOME ONLINE
ORGANIZER. SO TURN OVER THE
DIGITAL WORKFORCE OBVIOUSLY THE
RAPID. VERY LARGE EXPANSION OF
THAT ARE OF THOSE OF US IN
ABOUT IT DECADE. THIS START
SOME DELBERT COUNT OF FRONT AND
I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT. THAT
SHOULD BE DONE SO ALL THAT GETS
ME THE STATE PROJECT FOR YOU'LL
TALK JOB QUALITY OF. WORKING
CONDITION AND SEE TECHNICAL.
JANE YOU KNOW WE WANT TO BE
SMART ABOUT ALL THIS ONE OF
ATTENTION TO THIS IS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE WRECKING. WHAT WHAT
DEFINES. CLEARLY THE AVERAGE
WORK ON JOB ARE NOT. JOHN GOOD
JOB. THE STATISTICS. JUST
HAMMER DOWN SO NOW THIRTY YEARS
LATER WE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT NOW.
IT'S GOING TO START WITH THIS
THIS GAUGE WITH THE WE HAVE THE
EAST GATE- TEACHERS LOCAL
NINETY THREE TO. ON THE GROUND
ON THAT ISSUE ALONG ALONG WITH
THE NUMBER. WE FILED A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THAT DEVELOPMENT. SCENE
HE BREAKS YOUR- TALK ABOUT.
BENEFITTED REMAIN IN PLACE OF
THE TECHNOLOGY COMMUNITY OF THE
ROAD. FIREMAN BUT ALSO HAVE
SOME GUARANTEE OF WHAT THE JOB.
BECAUSE I HAVE SEEN HUNDREDS
THOUSAND JOBS. MANY JOBS.
TWENTY THERE'S NOT A LOT OF THE
JOB. SHOW. SO TALK ABOUT
EASTGATE PROBABLY GONNA BE
AMAZON NOW I ONE OF THE I THINK
THE TWO WHERE YOU LIVE OUR
STATE OF THE PRIVATE FOR ONE.
SO NOW I AM IS A LARGE PRIVATE.
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCES AB. THE
STAFF BENEFITS PROGRAM.
BUILDING OUR FUTURE ALSO THE
LARGER PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYER
NEWMAN EMPIRE ASSEMBLY. JUST
TALK ABOUT AMAZON DELIVERY
DRIVER WHICH IS A UPS AMAZON
DRIVER. STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE
YOU DRIVER CAN AFFORD PURCHASE
A HOME. FOR THE LIVING. DO ALL
THAT WAS ON IS NOT RECEIVING.
SORT OF LUXURY FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK THEY PROBABLY WOULD YOU
CAN USE OUR THAT'S A VERY GOOD
JOB WE NEED TO THE CONTRACT.
ALSO GROWN THIS RATHER BASED ON
THE BACK OF ALL THE WORKERS.
TALK ABOUT THAT WE WANT TO
BRING A UP WITH AMAZON AND B.
OCCUPANTS. FAMILY YES WE NEED
TO DEVELOPMENT THERE WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE. PAYING ATTENTION
BILLS ON AND USE IT TO OUR
ADVANTAGE SO WE CAN HAVE A GOOD
JOB. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN WHAT
WE NEED BENEFITTED WE MAY. WELL
THE MUSIC THESE. ALMOST TWENTY
A BIG SHOUT OUT TO ALL OF YOU.
I DON'T KNOW YEAH. ONE OF.
REPORT ON QVC WAREHOUSE IS. AND
YEAH BOB OR. WE KNOW WHO ALL
THE WORK WE REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE- YEAH. IT SHOWED A HALF
OF DOLLAR TAX GIVEAWAY OVER
FOUR YEARS TO. LAWYERS COME IN
AND DOESN'T PRODUCE A LOT OF
GOOD JOB WE STILL CAN'T FIND
DECENT JOB THE PROPERTY SO DO
WE HOW DOES THAT. ALL IN ALL WE
DO ALL THE NEW TAXES SO WHY ARE
WE GIVING AWAY THAT. DOESN'T
MAKE A LOT SO WE CAN REALLY
BENEFIT. OUTLINED I'M NOT JUST
THE WHAT GOING TO BE GOOD.
REALLY BUT ALSO WHAT THE JOB
LOOK LIKE YEAH YEAH LABOR GETS.
DIVIDED ON WHETHER MANY
BENEFITS LOOKS LIKE. LA THE ME
IN THE ALL THE- OTHER. ALL THE
WAS TO BE ON THE SAME PAGE. AS
A REALITY YOU KEY HE- BILL.
BUILDINGS IN EVEN IF THEY DON'T
DEAL MAKING THE- UNION FOREST'S
WITH THE BUILDING. YOU'RE LEFT
WITH HUNTER OF THOUSANDS OF. IN
ON FIGHTING OF. RESOURCE. BY
BACK IN THE WEEK AND BY
BUILDING SPEC BUILDING AND
DOING THE THINGS ARE GOING ON
IN THIS INDUSTRY. AND NOT
HOLDING IN TEN IS GOING TO BE
IN THE IN PALATABLE. WHAT THE
JOB LOOKS LIKE WITH CITY OR
REGION THAT'S WHAT REALLY BAD.
AND WHAT WE'RE ASKING I GOT.
ALL KINDS OF CRAZY IDEAS OF
WHAT. CALL RIGHT. LIVING IN
THESE LIVING LIVE LIVE LIVE IN.
THE WORKERS WERE ALSO A LOT.
HELP THE STORE I COULD TELL.
BECAUSE THE CREDIBLE THIS IS
WHAT I THE WORKING AND IT'S
GETTING WORSE IT'S NOT GETTING
BETTER IT'S ACTUALLY GOING THE
OTHER WAY AND IN AND WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING REALLY BEEN
AGREEMENT. THREE BENEFIT WE
NEED AND IF THERE'S A POLICY
ORDERS. BENEFIT ME IN MANY
BENEFITS. AND EVERYBODY HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE SO. SORRY MY
BAD YEAH YOU GOT SO EXCITED THE
ALL OF YOU WERE HERE- SO TALK
ABOUT QVC. BRIEFLY THIS SHOWS
THAT HOW MUCH MONEY WE- BACK TO
THIS LARGE EMPLOYER WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AMERICA YOU HAVE.
A LITTLE GO TO VICTORIA CLARKE
SEE IF TAX ONE OF THE VERY
BOTTOM. YOU'LL 9% TAX WILL
REALIZE HALF THAT MONEY GOING
BACK SOMEONE ELSE SOME SEXY
GOING TO THE DEL. WOULD TO BASS
PRO SHOP IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
GOING TO THE CITY IS NOT GOING
TO THE STATE. MOBILE FOR GOING
ON. AND THEN THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF JOBS. PLACE WE SEE IT FEELS
LIKE THE SHOULD BE GOOD POLICY
LAID OUT. IT IS A CV MAYBE
BENEFITTED RE CHANGES GO TO WHO
SAID THAT THE TABLE. CURRENTLY
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ARE DEVELOPER
TALKING. MAY THEY'LL WORK IT
OUT ALL. NOW WE PROGRAMS LABOR
AND EVERYONE ELSE. HOPING WE
CAN CONVINCE THE CITY. I THINK
HOPING SO ON THE- SIDE WITH THE
V. EIGHT WHAT THAT DOES IS IT
JUST KIND OF WHICH IS EVERYBODY
THIS IS ABLE FIND THE RIGHT OF
MY MIND. I THINK WITH THE CPA
ALL OF A NEIGHBORHOODS BE A LOT
BETTER JOB TO BE A LOT BETTER
EVERYBODY'S GOT A. IN THE-
CITY'S. AND EVERYONE. START
START MOVING ELECTION THIS YEAH
A LOT BETTER DEVELOP. I TALKED
TO DOING. THERE WERE NO REPORTS
OF REALLY TRY TAKE THE HIGH
ROAD GALLIMORE MORE MORE THAN
THIS AMOUNT. RESIDENTS REALLY
APPRECIATE IT DONALD TRUMP.
BEHIND US ON THAT AS WELL BEEN
ON. SHOT ON YALL RESIDENTS WE
CAN HANDLE NEIGHBORHOODS AND
AMAZING IF THEY'RE NOT GOING.
THE SOME OF THE OWNERS. SOME OF
LOS. I'VE BEEN HEARING CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS. SAY THAT THEY KNOW
THAT. THEY KIND OF GOTTEN AWAY
WITH THAT LAST YEAR. THEY
HAVEN'T DONE. AND I THINK IT'S
TIME WE ALL SIT DOWN.
LEAD UP
TO THE QUESTION WHAT. VERY VERY
SPECIFICALLY MAYBE A ONE HERE
TO THERE WHAT OTHER THINGS
LEGISLATURE CAN DO VERY. VERY
GOOD. THIS SITE THIS IS THE
NEXT SESSION ACTUALLY START TO
IMPACT THE ISSUES OF. BUT I
SAFETY AND HOW TECHNOLOGIES
BEING USED IN THIS CASE. IT
SEEMS LIKE TO. INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF INJURIES RATHER THAN.
SO I DIDN'T JUMP IN BUT- JUST
WANT TO PUT THAT OUT THERE IN
TERMS OF SPECIFIC LEGISLATION
OUR IDEAS ARE FALSE IDEAS THAT
YOU THINK WOULD ACTUALLY BE A
BACK TO THE NOT JUST WITH.
FIRST OF ALL I WILL SAY. THIS
IS LIKE WE ARE JUST AT THE
FRONT EDGE OF. RIGHT AS I THE
ONE THING WE NEED IS GATHERING.
OF FOLKS LIKE THIS- TO HASH OUT
WHAT IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
FOR. THAT SAID I THINK- IT IS
CAL OSHA. RESPONSIBILITIES TO
BE TRACKING THESE AND SO THE
MORE THAT CAL OSHA CAN GET
INVOLVED IN THIS THAT. THAT THE
TRACKING OF INJURY RATES AND
THEN TRIGGER INVEST IN THE
PARTICULAR FACILITIES. AND THEN
YOU ANALYZE THE PATTERNS ACROSS
THOSE FACILITIES AND START
GETTING AT THE ROOT CAUSES. OF
INJURY RATES- AND START TO
DEVELOP AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
FROM THERE I WOULD SAY I JUST
WANT TO ADD ONE OTHER THING I
ALWAYS WANT TO TRADE THE
ATTENTION NOT ONLY ON THE
PHYSICAL. HEALTH AND SAFETY BUT
MENTAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL WE
KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE AND I THINK THE
LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
ARE GOING TO BE BORNE BY THE-
FIRST AND FOREMOST BY THE
INLAND EMPIRE. I'M SO I THINK
STARTING TO DEVELOP WAYS OF
TRACKING THAT VERY NEW- BUT
STARTING TO. FORCE FORCE-
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY PUT. THANK YOU. THE
OTHER ABOUT MORE TO BE DONE IN
THE SHORT TERM TO BE.
DESTRUCTIVE DRESS. YEAH I
THINK- INVESTIGATION OF INJURY
RATES AND ALSO YOU KNOW WHAT
WHERE THESE CASES OF- WITH
THESE WITH THESE RATES OF
OPERATION PRODUCTION OR COMING
FROM AND WHY YOU KNOW WHY THEY
SAID IT IS OUR STANDARD THAT
STORY'S WORKERS AND SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING FOUR
BOXES PER MINUTE BEFORE AND
THEN ONE DAY THEY JUST TOLD US
SIX. AND THEY DIDN'T TELL US
WHY AND IT'S NOT ARBITRARY
THERE'S DEFINITELY RESEARCH
HAPPENING AROUND WHY THEY'RE
DOING THIS IN THERE SAYING THIS
IS HOW FAST WE CAN MOVE PEOPLE-
IN CERTAIN IN AMAZON THEY HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED THE POWER OUR
FOR THE BASE TO TAKE AN HOUR
THEY SAY WHOEVER MOVES THE
FASTEST THIS HOUR YOU GET A
FIVE DOLLAR GIFT CARD THE
PEOPLE THIS RUSH JUST AS FAST
AS THEY CAN TO YEAH THERE I GOT
BORED OF DO IT OKAY ALWAYS GOES
OUT SO I CAN. ANY BASE A TRYING
TO HELP THEY CAN MOVE THE AND
HOW FAST THEY CAN PUSH PEOPLE I
THINK THAT'S POINT ABOUT
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT AS WELL ON
WE HAD WORKERS TO COME TO SAY
WHAT'S THE BIG ISSUE HERE LOOK
WORRIED ABOUT ACTED. UPON WAS
THAT. WE'RE SO STRESSED OUT
PEOPLE FREAK OUT BUG OUT IN WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING HAPPEN
IN WITH NO WE KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF FISHING ROOM HEALTH VERY
COMPLICATED WE THINK THAT THIS
IS PUSHING PEOPLE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT WAYS. SO WE THAT
THERE TO BE KIND OF COPPER IN
ELSE BUT I AGAIN WHAT WE SEE
ENOUGH FROM THE RESEARCH AND
FROM WORKERS AND STUFF IS PLACE
OF WORK IS SOMETHING THAT THE
YOU KNOW THE KELLERS SHE'S
WORKING ON SKINNER YOU KNOW GOT
IT FOR. FIFTEEN YEARS NOW THERE
HAS TO BE IN A PLAN TO REBUILD
LIKE WHAT IS THIS NEW WHERE
WERE THESE YEAH. I WOULD ALSO
AGREE THAT. THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE MONITORING OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND AND-
YOU KNOW THERE'S- LABOR LAW
VIOLATIONS IF YOU KNOW HAVE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY. VIOLATIONS
BUT ALSO IN. WE HEAR REPORTS TO
ABOUT EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
IS. ABOUT YOU KNOW INSUFFICIENT
WORK BREAKS AS WELL WHICH I
THINK IS ALSO RELATED TO. TO
SOME OF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF. ISSUES THAT. WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER- YOU KNOW
THAT THE SIZE OF THESE
FACILITIES IS ENORMOUS RIGHT SO
GETTING TO THE BREAK ROOM. AND
THE RESTROOMS- ON TOP OF THE
FACT THAT SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO
GO THROUGH. THE SECURITY AND
THAT TAKES A LONG TIME TO GET
THROUGH THE SECURITY TO GET TO
THE BREAK ROOM. RIGHT AND YEAH
IT TAKES A TOLL. PHYSICALLY AND
IN TERMS OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
AS WELL THE JUST THE STRESS
LEVELS- I THINK WHATEVER THE
STATE CAN DO TO. TO KIND OF
HELP LOW THEY OWN YOU KNOW THE-
RATES WHICH ARE JUST. AND
REASONABLE RATES AND-
PHYSICALLY THESE ARE JUST. TOO
HIGH RIGHT AND YOU KNOW WHAT.
HI I'M NOT SURE THE EXACT NECK.
THAT YOU KNOW BUT I JUST THINK
THAT. THERE NEEDS TO BE SET
MORE WORK FOR PROTECTION I
PERSONALLY. FEEL LIKE THERE
NEEDS TO BE MORE PROTECTION FOR
THE WORKERS ON THE GROUND THESE
RATES ARE JUST AND REASONABLE.
NOT JUST THAT. MAKING RATE BUT
ALSO BEING SURVEILLED ABOUT HOW
MUCH TIME OFF TASK EXACTLY YOU
KNOW. WHICH YOU KNOW. LEADS TO
THINGS LIKE IT'S LIKE PEOPLE
NOT BE ABLE TO USE THE FACT
THAT I MEAN THAT'S A HUMAN NEED
AT THAT PEOPLE HAVE RIGHT AND
IT WAS ON- HAS- WOMEN WHO ARE
PREGNANT. SUING AMAZON RIGHT
BECAUSE IT. TO THE BATHROOM YOU
KNOW WHEN THEY NEEDED TO RUN IN
YOU KNOW IT'S A- PREGNANCY
DISCRIMINATION RIGHT SO I THINK
YOU KNOW. THERE'S ALL SORTS OF
THE LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS- THAT
THAT REALLY NEED TO ATTENTION.
SO THERE. TO BE PERFECTLY
HONEST THERE'S NO. WITH THE
ANSWER- YOU KNOW I. WHERE ELSE
PERSON MYSELF AND ACTUALLY
NEGOTIATING THESE ITEMS EVERY
EVERY ISSUE THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT
UP HERE UNDER COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT IS
ACTUALLY THE BUDGET. WE WORK
THROUGH RIGHT TO WORK THROUGH
THE SAFETY ISSUE WORK THROUGH
THE ORGAN ON. CERTAIN THINGS WE
GO I THINK THAT WHAT YOU COULD
DO WHAT COULD BE DONE IS TO SIT
DOWN WITH LABOR EXCLUSIVELY AND
TRY TO IDENTIFY THE ISSUE
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT'S A MATTER
OF GIVEN THESE INDIVIDUALS
QUICKER ACCESS TO THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. QUICKER
ACCESS TO THEM TO BUILD
ORGANIZE. THE SYSTEM HAS BEEN
BUILT IN THE WIG TO MAKE IT
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
HAVE THAT LAYS ON THE JOB. AND
THEN OSHA ALL OF ENTITIES ARE
OVER RUN. WITH ALL OF THE
COMPLAINTS AND EVERYTHING'S
GOING ON EVERYWHERE. THEY DON'T
HAVE BY THE TIME THEY GET TO
INVESTIGATING SOMETHING.
SOMEBODY SO THERE AYE SHE MOVED
ONTO ANOTHER. SO SHORT TERM
LABOR DOWN IN THE SCHOOLS OF
THE- I NEVER READ MOTHER. ON
THEIR ROB. THOSE OPERATE INSIDE
THE WAREHOUSES TYPES OF
WATCHING. SECOND WOULD BE
LOOKING HOW WITH THE HAPPENS
AFTER. I WOULD I WOULD I WOULD
OUT HER WITH THAT- YOU KNOW
THAT FROM THE WORKERS ARE WE
TALKED TO YOU KNOW THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT JUST HOW HOSTILE
VERY WE'RE HOUSE OF BLUES ON TO
USE YOU KNOW IT JUST SIMPLY
RETALIATION RIGHT ANOTHER LABOR
LAW VIOLATIONS. SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS. WE NEED WE NEED MORE.
ONE OF THE THINGS. YOU KNOW.
SOME REAL. HI MY. BUT I THINK
AND THEN AS- DATA- ON THE-
REQUEST INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DATA THAT'S BEING COLLECTED ON
THEM- HOW THAT HOW THAT CAN
APPLY TO WAREHOUSES I THINK IS
THAT- AND ONE OF THE BIG-
CHANGES THAT TECHNOLOGIES TO
PRODUCE IS IT IS FURTHER
INFORMATION ASYMMETRY SO
EMPLOYERS ARE COLLECTING MORE
DATA ON THEIR WORKERS WHICH
GIVES THEM MORE POWER IN THAT
RELATIONSHIP IT'S AS MUCH AS WE
CAN. START TO KIND OF REVIEW-
BUT SOME OF THAT DATA IS I
THINK WE CAN. GET BACK TO
LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD A
LITTLE BIT MORE BETWEEN WORKERS
AND- THANK YOU I KNOW WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH ALL OF YOUR
YOUR SUGGESTIONS AND EVEN MORE
SUGGESTIONS I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE. ALL YOUR BILLION MINDS AS
THE NUMBERS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS YOU HAVE. SO AS A
REPRESENTATIVE RIGHT HERE IN
RIVERSIDE THIS ISSUE IS VERY
PERSONAL TO- I HAVE IN MY
OFFICE HERE IN RIVERSIDE
CLIMATE WELL. GOVERNMENT
LEVELS- WENT TO POLY HIGH
SCHOOL HER MOTHER ENVIRONMENT
WORK IN THE WAREHOUSE. CARMEN
PERSONALLY HAS THE STORIES OF
HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS TO WORK IN
THE WAREHOUSES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. I I'VE BEEN SERVING
SEVEN YEARS NOW IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE BUT BEFORE I WAS
ELECTED- ANOTHER STUDENT OF
MINE PROBABLY HIGH SCHOOL ANGEL
ARIZA. FROM CASABLANCA. WORK
WITH THE- WAREHOUSE WORKER
RESOURCE CENTER AND ANGEL
BEFORE GOING ON TO PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY WORKED THAT SUMMER
AS I AND I FORGET THE TERM
GOING IN- YOU KNOW JUST
APPLYING FOR JOBS. BUT WELL
THERE'S A TERM THE LABOR HAS.
SALTY ANGEL ARIZA WORK DOING
THAT IN THE WAREHOUSE AND HE
WAS ABLE TO GET LOTS OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CONDITION
OF THE OF THE WAREHOUSES AND
THIS WAS AS I SAY PROBABLY
EIGHT NINE YEARS AGO ANGEL WENT
ON TO GRADUATE FROM PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY. STUDY RECENTLY CAME
OUT FORGET THE NAME OF THE
GROUP THAT DID THE STUDY. BUT
IT LOOKED AT YOUNG PEOPLE
GROWING UP IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND IN THAT STUDY CAME OUT THE
LAST FEW WEEKS IDENTIFIED
BAKERSFIELD. YEAH MY APOLOGIES
TO MY COLLEAGUE RUDY SALAS AS
THE WORST PLACE TO GROW UP AS A
YOUNG PERSON. AS A CHILD. RIGHT
BEHIND BAKERSFIELD WAS THE
INLAND EMPIRE. RIVERSIDE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE WAS RATED NUMBER
FIVE. WORST PLACE TO GROW UP AS
A YOUNG PERSON PART OF THAT IS
WAGES CLIMATE. IN ERROR
CONDITIONS- IN THE AREA. AS WE
HEAR SIT HERE AND LISTEN TO THE
CONDITIONS IN THE WAREHOUSES I
AM REMINDED OF THE EFFORT THE
FARM WORKERS HAD TO GO. THE
EFFORTS THE FARMWORKERS ANOTHER
LATINO WORK. HAD TO GO THROUGH
TO GET RECOGNIZED TALK ABOUT
NOT BEING ABLE TO USE THE BACK.
I REMEMBER IN THE FIELD WHEN
THERE WERE NO ABOUT. YOU KNOW
YOU TALK ABOUT HAVING THE RATE.
OF HAVING TO WORK FASTER AND
FASTER. FIREMAN TELLS ME
STORIES ABOUT BEING INTIMIDATED
TO HAVE TO DO OVERTIME. COMMENT
ON SUNDAY. SO I DO HAVE A
QUESTION. BECAUSE. HAVING LIVED
HERE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE BY
THE LONG TIME I REMEMBER AS YOU
SPEAK. TIES ARE STILL BY THE
UNION JOB. AND PENSIONS HIGH
PAYING JOB SO MY QUESTION- WHAT
ARE. YOU KNOW I KNOW THE
EFFORTS OF BEEN GOING ON FOR
AWHILE. TO USE. AND I APPLAUD
THOSE UP. WHAT IS IT THAT WE
CAN DO AS LEGISLATORS SITTING
UP HERE AS A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THIS AREA IN SACRAMENTO
WHAT IS IT THAT WE CAN DO RIGHT
TO ADDRESS. THE DIFFICULTY IN
BEING ABLE TO USE. WHAT IS
THERE ANYTHING SPECIFIC. READ
THAT WE CAN DO IS I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO INTRODUCE SUCH
LEGISLATION. KIND OF ASSUMING
THAT AT MY DIRECTION RIGHT. YOU
KNOW I'D SAY TAKE A POLL OF
APPROACH I'D SAY YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED IN THE
RECENT PAST. IS IT. CLAIMS TO
BE PREEMPTED BY THE NATIONAL
LABOR RELATIONS ACT. I THINK
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
COULD TAKE SOME VERY BOLD. STEP
RECOGNITION PROCESS FOR
WORKERS. WE CAN IMPORT.
PROCESSES FOR WORKERS TO BE
ABLE TO ORGANIZE ON A MUCH
FASTER PACE. BY GOING TO CITY
GOVERNMENT AND ACTUALLY HAVING.
THE STATE LEVEL ITSELF FOR SOME
SORT OF SYSTEM THAT MOVES OUT
ALONG MUCH FASTER I. ABSOLUTELY
REMEMBER KAISER STEEL I WAS.
FONTANA I WAS DELIVERY PAPERS
YEARS OLD LONG SHUTTING DOWN.
THE SHUTDOWN OF THAT STILL MILL
AND AT THE TIME WE GAVE UP I
THINK THAT THE TIME IN THE
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES OR WHAT
MUCH UNDERSTANDING FIREMAN AND
HOW THE LONG TERM IMPACT.
PEOPLE WHO GAVE UP. WHAT
HAPPENED. BYRON POLICE GOOD JOB
RIGHT THERE'S A TRADE OFF BUT
NOW WE KNOW TODAY WE GOT TO BE
SMART ABOUT FOR. FORTUNATELY
NOW THE OPPOSITE HAPPENED
THERE'S NOT GOOD JOB. AND ON
TOP OF IT WE HAVE TO BUY OR
MENTAL. SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
DOUBLE IF NOT A TRIPLE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS ISSUE. SO MY ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION IS FOR PEOPLE. TO
BE MORE AGGRESSIVE THE ALLOWING
PROCESSES. IN OTHER WORDS
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENT.
FOR SOME SYSTEM AT THE STATE
LEVEL. WHICH IS A SON OF VICE
CITY'S. FOR THEM TO INVOICE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENT-
YOU COULD ONE HAVE PENALTIES.
THAT PREVENT- LET'S SAY IT. THE
DEVELOPER COMES AND GET SOME
SORT OF INFRASTRUCTURE- CREDIT
EIGHT MINUTES WHATEVER IT MAY
BE TO CALL A MILLION DIFFERENT
THINGS NOW RIGHT. ON THE MONEY
SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE SYSTEM.
THAT THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED. TO
USE UNION ABSOLUTELY NOT WHILE
YOU'RE GETTING CREDIT FROM SOME
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDY SOME LEVEL.
HOW IS IT THAT THEY- WILL GOING
TO ORGANIZE. A SENSE OF USING
THAT SAME. FOR UNION OF WHITE
SO IT'S GOOD ANNA. SAMPLE
AMAZON THE PAY IN. RIGHT NOW
THOUGH. EMPLOYER IN EMPIRE THE
TURNOVER RATE. IS LIKE ONE OF
THE SOUL STUDY ON 3% WE HAD A
PERCENT ONE YEAR OF FACILITY.
OF OVER A THOUSAND PEOPLE HOW
YOU EVEN GET THROUGH THAT
PROCESS. NOW WHAT YOU DO IS YOU
GET THE LOCAL ELECTED TO START
SAYING HEY WE'RE GONNA CHANGE
THE RULES. IN HOW YOU ARE AN
EMPLOYER IN MY CITY. I THINK
THAT WHAT THE STATE TO DO IS
ACTUALLY. PUT SOMETHING IN
PLACE. SENATE OR PENALTY I KNOW
YOU RATHER DO A CHARACTER IN
THE STATE. GOT TO BE REALISTIC.
I'VE GOT LIKE. ONE THIRTY IDEAS
YOU WANT TO SIT DOWN AND THAT.
ALSO LIKE TO HEAR FROM. I THINK
YEAH MOSTLY WHAT. THAT IS.
BECAUSE OF THE WE ALL THE
CITY'S SUBSIDIZE. YEAH THE
OTHER ONE COUNTY. SO YOU GOT.
WE HAVE A ONE OF THE YEAH
THAT'S- DOES HAVE GENERAL FOR.
TO STABILIZE. TO BE ABLE TO.
THE TURNOVER RATE MAKES IT
HARDER FOR. TO BE ABLE TO GET
TO KNOW EACH OTHER. JOINT. THE
BREAK. THANK YOU FOR BEING
ELECTED THREE YEARS AGO I. I
REPRESENTED A WHOLE LOT OF
PEOPLE. AND IT WAS A LONG. ALL
WORK. MORE YOU. SO WE'RE HEALTH
WORKERS ARE BEING INJURED IT
ALMOST DOESN'T MATTER I WOULD
HAVE YOU TALKED ABOUT A REPORT
THE AMAZONS DISPOSABLE WORKERS
TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S SAYS IT
ALL. WHEN YOU DON'T CARE WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO YOUR WORKERS THEN
EVERYTHING ELSE EVER EVER.
BOTTOM LINE IS ALL THAT
MATTERS- IN THAT IS OF GREAT
CONCERN I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT THE BILL THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA
INTRODUCED WE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. CALLS FOR THOSE
STUDIES AND THE ONCE WE HAVE
THOSE STUDIES WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DO SO MUCH MORE WITH
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE THE HARD
FACTS. WE HAVE A LOT OF IT FROM
WHAT YOU WERE PROVIDED TO US.
AND WHEN YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
THE ARE ARE FARMWORKERS THAT.
WILL PICKING ONIONS ARE GREAT
AND VERY PROUD OF THAT WORK.
WITH THE FARM WORKERS WORKED
REALLY HARD TO GET RID OF THE
SHORT HANDLED. HOE AND THAT
WAS. FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
FORMER OWNERS- BUT IT TOOK A
LONG TIME WAS FINALLY. DONE I
THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO
THE SAME THING YOU HAVE WITH
THE CHAIR OF. THE LABOR
COMMITTEE FOR THE ASSEMBLY.
LEADING THIS AND LISTENING TO
THIS TESTIMONY HE'S BEEN A
GREAT ADVOCATE FOR WORKERS AND
I KNOW THAT BETWEEN THE THREE
OF US WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME
UP WITH SOME LEGISLATION. SO
YOU'VE TOLD US SOME OF IT NOW.
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU THAT IF
YOU THINK OF OTHER IDEAS. THAT
YOU LET US KNOW- INDIVIDUALLY
OR THROUGH THROUGH THE CHAIR.
LET US KNOW ABOUT YOUR
SUGGESTIONS. BECAUSE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ACTUALLY NEED
TO. DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE CAL
OSHA PART. I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN START
MOVING ON. YOU DO BENEFIT
AGREEMENT. I THINK WE HAVE TO
FIND A WAY TO KEEP THOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- IT IS TOUGH TO
TELL YOU SAID THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING JUST STARTING TO HAVE
IN DEPTH CONVERSATIONS EVEN
THOUGH I KNOW MANY OF YOU WORK
MANY YEARS. ADDING TO THE POINT
WHERE IT IS REALLY GETTING
PUBLIC. PUBLIC PERCEPTION IS
CHANGING AND CERTAIN THE
LEGISLATURE'S WHILE SO. THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH- FOR YOU FOR
YOUR WAS DONE AND I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE HEARING FROM YOU AND
TALK. TO A LOT MORE. IN THE
MONTHS AND YEARS AHEAD SO-
THAT'S IF WE- MOVE FROM ONE
PANEL TO THE NEXT- THE OTHER
PANELISTS TO THESE. THIS IS A
YEAR AND- YOU DON'T SAID BUT I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES JUST REALLY
I THINK SET UP THIS NEXT PANEL
TO THE WELL AND WE ALSO HEARD
FROM. MISTER CORGAN SOME
DISMISSIVE MR WORKERS SOMETIMES
DOES NOT A CAREER OR IS LOW
WAGE WILL ALL THAT STUFF REALLY
COMES ON THE DVD. ARE WE GONNA
HAVE DIGNITY FOR OUR WORKERS
AND DIGNITY IN OUR WORK. AND
THAT'S WHY EVERYONE OF MY
INFORMATION HEARINGS I ALWAYS
HAVE A PANEL THAT HAS WORKERS
SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO. AND WE'RE
GONNA DO THIS THING RIGHT NOW-
HEARING FROM. SOMEONE UP. OSCAR
MIKE AND JOHN. WELL HERE THAT'S
ONE OF THE VISION. THE FIRST UP
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE- AND I
DON'T WANT TO SAY I KNOW THE
FOR THE FOR A LOT OF THE
WORKERS THIS IS NOT YOUR NORMAL.
YOU GET A PUBLIC VENUE LIKE
THIS SO WE- YOUR COURAGE IN
COMING FORWARD TO TELL YOUR
STORY AND WE HAVE WITH US ALSO
BORROWS. A WAREHOUSE WORKER WHO
HAS WORKED AT TWO TWENTY
LABORATORIES WHICH IS COSMETICS
WAREHOUSE SERVING MAC SAPPORO
INDUSTRY LOUDER. THANK YOU FOR
BEING OSCAR MIKE CLARK A
WAREHOUSE WORKER WHO IS DR
PEPPER SNAPPLE AND THE
TEAMSTERS LOCAL NINETY THIRTY
TWO MEMBERS THANK YOU MIKE AND
THEN JOHN THE DOES NOT. FORMER
TRUCK DRIVER FOR UNIVERSAL
REMOTE THAT OUR MOBILE
SERVICES. A MEMBER OF TEAMSTERS
LOCAL EIGHT FOUR EIGHT THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR THE- WELL
AND YOU HAVE ONE MORE
INDIVIDUALS. AND. YEAH
EVERYBODY YEAH- AND YOU CAN YOU
CAN HIS INTERVIEWS YOURSELF
WITH THE TEAMSTERS. OKAY. OKAY
AND SO ONE OF YOU ARE JUST A
FEW MINUTES AND JUST. TELL YOUR
STORY I MEAN THAT'S A THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT. TAKE
FOR FIVE MINUTES SO HOW MUCH.
IF YOU NEED THAT MUCH AND THEN
THE MOTION THAT'S FINE BUT TO
SHARE YOUR STORY THE- BEST YOU
CAN THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. BE
ABLE THANK YOU SOON GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS OSCAR ROCK I
LIVE IN THE STATE OF MONTANA
CALIFORNIA AND I'M SURE ABOUT
MY ISSUES WORKING FOR THE
DECLINE IN THE WORKPLACE-
TWENTY LABORATORIES THIS IS
SEVEN NINETY FOUR ROUGHLY FLAT
BLACK DISTILLERY IN SUPPORT OF.
SOME THERE'S SOMEONE THIS
FACILITY SINCE GOOD TO STORES.
I WON THE REGENCY SOME ANY SOME
CASES A SINGLE WATER TEMPLE
COST MORE THAN A HUNDRED
DOLLARS ORDERS ALMOST ALL WOMAN
FOR CONTROL AND ALSO A STOP IN
THE UC AND NINE ONLY THE
MINIMUM WAGE. THE FIGHT
MONTEREY SPENT WITH THIS
COMPANY I. HAD A TOUGH TIME TO
SPEAK WITH THE WAY THE-
WAREHOUSE FOR. WHAT THEY
BELIEVE OKAY. THE PRODUCTION IS
STANDARDS IN RAISING HIS
WAREHOUSE FOR BETTY HI. WAY
HIGH IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE USE
OF. PUT UP- FOR PEOPLE RUNNING
FOR MONTHS. RIGHT IN FROM OF
THE CONVEYOR BELT. AND THEY
HAVE BECOME A SCOOP UP ONTO THE
BOTHERS. MINUTE FIFTY ONE THE
MANY PASSING THEM IS PLEASED TO
THEY HAVE. TO IN THE WAY OF
THEM. WITH IS. THIS IS A
EXAMPLE WOULD CANNOT PROSPER A
MOMENT OR BOTTOM MY LOVE AND
THE START. THIS FEELING OF
PRODUCT OVER THE BAY AND END OF
ON THE FLOOR THOUSAND BIG MAN
ON THE DURING THE SOME IS VERY
HIGH AND VERY HOT THEN THAT
WOULD HOW THEY DON'T HAVE A
SEAT. AND DON'T HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE ENOUGH TIMES TO GIVE
THE WORKERS SCHOOL. IS A THERE
IS POSSIBLE OF SEVEN HE SAID
THE ONE. THE BECAUSE OF THE
REVIEW OF THE THIS THE AT THE
DEBATE FAST REALLY HAVE
SOMETHING DATA DIDN'T EVEN HAVE
A CHANCE TO MEET WATER WHY
BECAUSE IT IS THE SAME REASON
THAT TO YOU THAT BEFORE THE
PRODUCT AND THE REMEMBER THE TO
SPEAK. THAT'S IN ALLOW COULD
NOT EVEN. THE SUPERBOWL IN THE
MANY THEY DON'T ALLOW IT TO
LIVE THERE WOULD BE JUSTICE
LEVEL. HEY ONE OF THE HARDEST
THINGS THAT I HAVE TO LIVE THIS
IS THE ONE MY GOAL SEE MICHAEL
IS. PAGE DO IN THE- AND THE
SOME BECAUSE OF HEAT. WITH THIS
HAVE A WEEK WE HAVE BEEN A MORE
OF. THE BILL AGES TO RECOVER.
SO IT IS VERY USEFUL OF THIS
THIS. TO SEE A LOT OF LADIES
THE BECAUSE THE- MOST OF
WORKERS SOMEONE. WHEN I OF AS A
SUPERVISOR FOR THESE WAREHOUSE
I TO MOVE MAKE CHANGES
OBVIOUSLY ELLISON SAYS BECAUSE
OF THE- AND SOME OF BECAUSE
SOME OF THE SOMEONE WORKERS
THAT WITH WORKING WITH THE
COMPANY FOR MANY YEARS AB AND
ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN IS THAT
THE RESPONSE WAS THIS IS THE
WAY IT'S BEING DONE FOR YEARS I
NEED THIS IS THE WAY YOU HAVE
TO BE DONE. AND I WAS THE
ASSISTANT. PERSONALLY I THINK
THAT OUT BILL ON IS OBVIOUSLY
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE- THERE
WILL FOR ALL OF THEM IT WILL BE
A NUMBER OF THE POLICE. AND
THEN HE IS ACTING MANAGEMENT
ONLY THINKING ABOUT- NUMBER.
SEVENTY NINE. SO ALSO SEE A LOT
OF WORKERS. NEW WORK IS THE
DATA YOU NEED TO USE THAT THE
STATUS WE BELIEVE BLOOD WITHIN
THE FIRST WEEK OF THE LAUNCH
CREATED THERE'S A LEAD IN THE
SCHOOL HI TO MOLD MAKING MORE
USE THIS IS. THE WAY IT THE
COMPANY OPERATES. AND NOT A
FOOT TO LEAVE UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT I SEE AND NOW WHAT IS THIS
FOR ME IS THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
THE DEBUTS THERE FOR YEARS THEY
GET USED TO ALL WORK DO IS BACK
CONDITIONS. AND BECAUSE THE
FINANCING IS. PROVIDE FOR THE
FROM. SO ANY AB ABU CHAIR SO
WITH SAY THAT. THEY NEED TO
START BEING A PATIENT THIS. A
STANDARDS RATES. SO MAKING MORE
REALISTIC. I DON'T KNOW HOW.
THERE IS SOMETHING YOU SAID
THAT I WAS THE WITH A LOT THERE.
USUALLY THE LATEST YEAH THE
SPEEDS OF THE STATE I DON'T
KNOW WHEN I WAS THERE I WAS
TRYING TO THE SLOWER. MODERATE
PHASE WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A
GOAL OF THESE MASK OFF AND
FORCING US TO STOP IT'S NOT THE
ONLY WAY THE PEOPLE HAVE A
CHANCE TO BE WATER. WINDOW
BROTHER MY LAP AND HELLO AND-
THE STAR SPILLING THAT FORCING
US TO STOP. SO THAT'S THEY RUN
THROUGH THE REST OF THE WATER.
THANK YOU. THEY CAN DO. SO I
THINK THIS. ON TO LOOK AT NOT
CONTROL THE SCHOOL. FOR A- THE
PEOPLE'S HEALTH IS SET THE VIEW
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH I THINK.
NEXT UP MY CLARK WAREHOUSE
WORKER. TEACHERS LOCAL NINETEEN.
CAN YOU MEDIA YES THERE. HELLO
PROBLEM MEMBER- NINETEEN-
THIRTY TWO AND- I'M UNION AND
THE STORIES THAT I HEAR A
REALLY BAD WE DON'T HAVE THAT
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE HAVE A CD
EIGHT CURRENT BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. SO WE DON'T FACE THE
PROBLEMS I'VE BEEN IN THE
WAREHOUSE ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
AND ALSO. THE RATE THAT. SPOKE
ABOUT. NINETEEN NINETY TWO I
STARTED AT THAT RATE THAT THEY
WERE I'M DOUBLE THAT NOW
BECAUSE ON TEACHERS ON UNION SO
UNION MAKE THE BALLOT THE- DAY.
BY THE BALLOT THE CORPORATION
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
WORKERS LIKE THE AMAZON THING
THAT I DO SYSTEM WE SPOKE ABOUT.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE A- A BARGAINING AGREEMENT
FOR RATE SO WE DON'T HAVE
ISSUES LIKE THAT. SO UNION HAVE
POWER BALANCE TO THE COMMUNITY
IT HELPS OUT FOR EVERYBODY SO.
I SO THIRTY YEARS. BOB WOULD BE
WELL AS WE'RE GOING. YES I HAVE
A PENSION I HAVE A LOT OF THE
TIME- RETIREMENT I HAVE GREAT
MEDICAL BENEFITS BUT BECAUSE WE
UNION. LIKE I SAID IS STRENGTH
IN NUMBERS. THESE PEOPLE AT
AMAZON THAT I'VE HEARD LIKE
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE THAT WORK
THERE THEY DON'T HAVE A VOICE
OR ANYTHING SO. IT'S REALLY BAD
THAT I. FOR MORE. I DON'T I
DON'T- WE DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES
YOU STILL ABLE TO WORK IN THE
CASE THAT ISSUE FOR THE COMPANY
RIGHT BECAUSE WE HAVE A KERN
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS SO THEY
SUPERVISORS CAN GET ONLINE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A CONTRACT. TO GET THE JOB
DONE. YEAH NO PROBLEM WE GET
THE JOB DONE. AND THERE'S NOT A
HIGH TURNOVER RATE LIKE. THAT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE HIGH
TROUBLING TRAIN SOMEONE ALL
THAT. THAT ACTUALLY ALSO. ALL
RIGHT. AND ALSO YES I LIVE IN
WHEN CUCAMONGA AND I MEAN I'M
PROUD AND THE MONEY THAT I MAKE
I MEAN I COULD THE MONEY THAT
THEY MAKE AYE YET I WOULD NEVER.
COULD I CAN'T BAN THEM. WITH
THE UNION LIKE I SAID EVEN.
SUPPORT YEAH THE SPORTS YEAH
BASKETBALL FOOTBALL BASEBALL
THEY ALL HAVE YOU LOOK AT THE
TYPE OF MONEY I MEAN YOU CAN
EXISTING POWER OF THE UNION
BEFORE SO IT GIVES THE PEOPLE
VOICE NOT ON THE ISLAND YOU'RE
NOT BY YOURSELF. YEAH
REPRESENTATION SO I'M A LITTLE
I MEAN I LOVE NINETEEN THIRTIES
ALL OF THE UNION I MEAN. HELLO
BUT- I KNOW A LOT ABOUT AYE
DADDY ON A PROFESSIONS ON THE
CAREER THAT WERE HELLO WHEN
RETIREMENT GO THE TEACHINGS I
WOULD AGREE SO I'M NOT DONE BUT
I MEAN IT'S NOT BAD WORK AYE
AYE LA I ENJOYED IT DOESN'T
BOTHER ME- I HAVE I HAVE I HAVE
LIKE SIX WEEKS OF VACATION SO.
I MEAN. I HAVE A LOT OF TIME
OFF SO I MEAN IT'S NOT LIKE.
THAT MR BY. ON THIS OCCASION
TIME DID YOU GET WHEN YOU WERE
WORKING AT THE. WITH THIS
COMPANY THAT WAS ON THE WALL WE
A YEAR. IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
MANY USERS. WHEN THE FORTY HOUR.
ALSO TO SAY I HAVE ALSO
HOLIDAYS WE HAVE YOU KNOW
CHRISTMAS ALL THE HOLIDAYS WE
HAVE EVERYTHING AND WE HAVE A
FLOATING HOLIDAY SO. WITH THE
UNION IF GIVES YOU GIVES YOU
THE BALLOT BECAUSE THAT WAY THE
COMPANY CAN'T JUST ONE A MONTH.
BECAUSE FROM WHAT I'M HEARING
THE CYCLE RUN IN THE MONTH. I
HAD SOME OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
GOING ON AT THAT'S NOT. WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE- I MEAN LOOK AT
EUROPE I DON'T I MEAN HOW THEY
DO THINGS WE SHOULD BE FOR
ALMOST THE WAY THE WAY THESE
COMPANIES ACT ACT LIKE THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY I MEAN THEY'RE
NOT. YOU KNOW NOT. YEAH I MEAN.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE YOU A LOT TO
TEACH SO WHAT'S YOUR NEXT
CAREER. THANK YOU MISTER CLARK
APPRECIATE YOUR INSIGHTS- NEXT
UP IS AND THE- TEAMSTERS LOCAL
THREE NINE SIX WEBSITE. THE UPS
AND- HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON- YEAH
LIKE I SAID MY NAME'S ANTHONY
VOICE YEAH MY WITH THE UPS SAN
GABRIEL. I GAVE- THE PACKAGE
AND- I WORKED THERE FOR FIVE
YEARS. I LOW TRADERS IN THE IN
THE TWILIGHT SHIFT. AND I AM-
TRAILERS THAT RANGE FROM LIKE
FIFTY THREE FOOT TRAILER TO ANY
ANY SESSION WHEN I FIRST
STARTED I WAS A ROOKIE- AYE
AYES THAT'S ON LOW LIKE- LIKE
TWELVE HUNDRED TWELVE HUNDRED
PACKAGES. AN HOUR LIKE FIFTEEN
MINUTES BUT THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
IT WAS. LIKE A LIKE A REAL KIND
OF LIKE. SPECIALLY DURING PEAK
SEASON SEASON HEAVY ON.
NOWADAYS I DON'T COUNT I DON'T
COUNTY NOBODY HOLD ME
ACCOUNTABLE NO WE CAN FIGHT
BACK LOW LIKE BASED ON THE SIZE
OF THE TRAILER BASED ON THE
SIZE OF THE PACKAGES LIKE.
SOMETIMES THEY'RE SMALL BACK.
HUGE HEAVY BACK SO ON THE IS
AND ALWAYS TAKE OUR FIFTY A LOT
OF THE REVIEWS THAT COME IN LOT
OF A YOU GUYS COME IN THEY TRY
TO THAT LIKE ONCE A PASSIVE. I
TRY TO TELL THEM LIKE TO WORK
STATE. WHICH WOULD SAVE MOST
POINT THESE STATE THAT THE
THAT'S A- MAY THING THAT THE
USE WOULD SAY NO THERE'S NO
COMPENSATION FOR FASTER YOU'LL
YOU'LL YOU'LL GET A METAL YOU
YOU DON'T GET A BONUS GO JUST
BREAK IT BACK. THE SAFETY
SHOULD ALWAYS BE FIRST. AND IF
THE TO HARASS YOU WILL BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THERE MANAGERS THAT
THE THAT THAT CHILD THERE'S A
FOR TURN AROUND WE MANAGE
ACTION. BUT THE MANAGER THEY
TRY TO COME TO YOU AND ON THE
BILL TRY TO WRAP THE WAY YOU
THERE'S LIKE HE SAID WE HAVE A-
WE HAVE A CONTRACT ALSO WHEN
THERE'S- RESPECT. IS BEING IN A
CONTRACT. YOU KNOW THERE'S
LANGUAGE ABOUT RESPECT IN THE
WAITING TREATING. SO WE STATE
LAWS FOR SAFETY- LIKE I LIKE
TALKING ABOUT SIXTIES FIRST- WE
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY. WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED WHEN FOR STUDY
YES THEY GIVE YOU LIKE THE
EXTENSIVE ORIENTATION REGARDING
THE YOU WATCH A LOT OF VIDEOS
ON BEFORE EVERY SHIFT. BEFORE
YOU SHIP THEM- WE HAVE A LIKE
MEETING. AB STRETCHES TALK
ABOUT SAFETY TIPS WE RARELY
TAKE QUIZZES LIKE THE THERE'S
LIKE A COMPUTER ON. A THE END
OF THE PROVIDE DEMONSTRATIONS.
I LIKE THE NEW ONE. WE ALSO
HAVE A SAFETY COMMITTEE THAT
WORKS WORK- THAT- WORKERS
VOLUNTEERED TO BE A PART OF
THEY TRY TO EACH OTHER LIKE.
THE COMPANY THE COMPANY ALSO
TRIES TO. SAVE ALSO WE STRIVE
TO WORK FOR A- LONG TIME
WITHOUT INJURY LIKE WE CAN GO
LIKE. BUDGET THE DAYS WHAT I NG.
A YEAR INJURIES LIKE DIFFERENT
SHIFTS SO DIFFERENT AREAS AND
WE CAN HAVE A CONTEST STUFF
LIKE THAT. SO YEAH SO I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE YOU KNOW THEY THEY
THEY THEY THEY CAN REPLACE YOU
BUT BUT BUT BUT YOU CAN'T
REPLACE IT BACK. TO ME LIKE
THEY COULD ALWAYS LACY BUT-
ONCE YOU'RE BACK MOST OF THAT.
SO GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT OF MY
HISTORY BEFORE I EVEN CAME TO
YOU YEAH- I WORKED AT WALMART.
AND WHEN I WORKED THERE I WORK
FULL TIME HOURS AND THEY WOULD
CALL ME A PART TIME OR SO I SEE
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE FENCE.
YOU KNOW I SEE I SEE HOW WAS
OVER THERE. SO THEY WOULD CALL
ME A PART TIMER AND I WOULDN'T.
I WOULDN'T QUALIFY FOR THE
BENEFITS. NO I WOULD HAVE WHY
WOULD A FULL TIME HOURS AND
EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE THERE. MY
HOURS THAT'S HOW THAT'S HOW
THAT WOULD WORK. MY FAMILY AND
I WERE ON FOOD STAMPS AND
MEDICAID OUT LIKE THEY WERE
SPEAKING ABOUT ARE YOU I LIVE
THAT. THAT MY SUPERVISOR WE OUT
I MEAN FOR THE CUSTOMERS THERE
WAS A LOT BETTER THERE A
WALMART- ANY EVENTUALLY I
JOINED- ORGANIZATION CALLED OUR
WALMART NOW IT'S KNOWN AS THE
UNITED FOR. RESPECT WHEN I
STARTED FOCUSING MORE WORK. I
KNOW WHERE A. MY DRIVE FOR THIS
FIGHT START A FARM SO AFTER
LEVY WALMART- I BECAME A
TEAMSTER AT U. P. S. LIKE I
MENTIONED ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO
AND I COULD TELL YOU THE GRASS
IS GREENER ON THE OTHER SIDE. I
WORK I'M A PART TIME WORKER
AND- I HAVE FULL TIME BENEFITS.
I HAVE A PENSION LIKE MY
BROTHER WRITER WAS TALKING
ABOUT. I HAVE A PENSION AND- I
HAVE ALL MY FAMILY ON MY
BENEFITS WE HAVE- WE HAVE A
LOCAL PAYMENT MY WIFE HAS A
GOOD JOB ALSO SHE WORKED FOR
PEPSI SHE HAS BENEFITS ALSO
BUT- IT'S NOT LIKE OURS. YOU
KNOW I HAVE A LOCAL PAYS.
THANKS TO THE LEADERSHIP OF
ROCK- RUN AROUND RIGHT JEFF
PHILLIPS. AND YEAH AND NOW NOW
THESE- WE DON'T WE DON'T DEPEND
ON. RIGHT NOW I'M IN THE
PROCESS OF A PACKAGE DRIVERS- I
WENT TO THE TRAINING AND ON.
NEXT WEEK ON THE FIFTEENTH I'LL
BE HEADING UP NORTH. TO MY
DRIVER CHANGE. IT'S ON THE
STRIVE FOR. THE I LEARNED A LOT
OF A LIKE I WOULDN'T I WENT ON
A RIDE ALONG- MY PACKAGE EVER
AND- I JUST WANT TO TOUCH OUR
LIKE SAFETY- I GOT TO LEARN A
LOT OF A LOT OF SAFETY TIPS ON
MY WAS OUT THERE AND SHOW ME
LIKE I'M MORE OF A HANDS ON
THEIR LEARNERS SO. KIND OF
PRESSED ON A LOT OF THE ISSUES
AND STUDYING NOW. FOR GREEN AND
ALL THAT I LEARNED A LOT OF
THESE I CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT
UPS UPS DRIVERS ARE SOME OF THE
STATE. I WAS OUT. RIGHT RIGHT
AND I'M LOOKING FOR TO BE A
PACKAGE DRIVERS. YEAH. I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT TO ME IS
ABOUT THE MOST WONDERFUL KNOW
MUCH OF A VOICE- WE HAVE THEIR
EYES WORK- YOU PS. YOUR MORE
RESPECTED BY MANAGERS- THEY
KNOW THAT THEY KNOW THAT WE
KNOW OUR UNION CONTRACT- YOU
CAN YOU CAN DEFINITELY HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE THIS TOWN
BILLY WITH SUPERVISORS- IS NOT
JUST A ONE WAY STREET WHERE
THEY CAN TELL YOU DO- THAT TO
TELL YOU WHAT TO DO LIKE WITH
RESPECT ROOM LIKE I MENTIONED-
YOU- I JUST WANT PEOPLE AND ALL
ON. THE POWER THAT THEY HAVE IN
THEIR HANDS. LIKE. HAVING A
VOICE OF THE ON THE JOB MATTER
ENOUGH FOR LIKE- MY JOB IS TECH
IS. AND I'M MORE RESPECTED.
YEAH. WELL JOHNNY NOT. DRIVER
FOR UNIVERSAL SERVICES NUMBER.
IT'S A GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS. JOHN THAT. COMES UP. I'M
HERE- BECAUSE WE HAVE A MY
COWORKER AND FRIEND- WHICH THEY
WILL BE HERE ACTUALLY SPEAKING
UP TO DATE- HE'S IN- YEARS
WITH- WIVES ACTUALLY- BETTY
CANCER. SO GLAD TO BE HERE FOR.
LIKE IT'S A MONEY JUMP THERE'S
ONE AND I WAS ON A TERMINATED
BY UNIVERSAL EVEN MORE
SERVICES- JUST ONE DAY BEFORE
THINGS GET. OKAY I'M FOR TRUCK
DRIVER. IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO PICK UP AND BRING BACK A
LITTLE TOO LATE AND LONG BEACH.
FOR IMPORT AND EXPORT I WOULD
LIKE TO THE OLD WALMART. MON
AMONG OTHER OTHER COMPANIES 40%
OF THE US ECONOMY MOVES THROUGH
THESE PORTS ON THE BACK OF OUR
TRUCK. OKAY I WAS WORKING FOR
UNIVERSAL. PROPERLY FOR LIKE A
YEAR AND A HALF. AND WILL BE
OUT OF THE BLUE OF. LAKE.
ACTUALLY TALK TO- ONE OF MY
COWORKERS AND LET HIM KNOW AS-
LIKE ALL THE BENEFITS WE COULD-
JOY JUST BEGIN BY UTILIZING
COMING SO WE ACTUALLY WHAT.
FIVE THROUGH THAT- THROUGH THE
WHOLE PROCESS LIKE I SAID I WAS
TERMINATED. WHAT THE BEFORE
THANKSGIVING AND JUST A WEEK
AWAY FROM OUR FROM OUR ACTUAL-
OLD THEY- TAXI WILL BE MEETING.
SO I WAS ACTUALLY- VERY
INVOLVED I WAS THE ONE ACTUALLY
SPEAKING OUT ABOUT THE- WE
ENJOYED A UNION BUSTING- FROM
THE COMPANY JUST. IT WAS JUST A
HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE- ACTUALLY-
SPOKE ABOUT- LITTLE NO- LET THE
UNIVERSITY DOES LIKE A TO
TELLING. ME LIES SO- ONE DAY I
GET I GET I GET IT TO WORK IN
THE MORNING LIKE LONG. TRAVEL
BLOCKING- BLOCK IN AND- MICHAEL
DIDN'T WORK. SO I COULD LOOK AT.
SO THE MANAGER FROM UNIVERSAL
OF ALL BE INTO THE OFFICE. WHEN
IN AND LET AND THEY LET ME KNOW
SELECT GAY WORD SUSPENDING YOU.
AND THE REASON WAS I BECAUSE I
HAD NOT A SINGLE LIKE. WELL I
GUESS IT PREVIEW PREVIOUS TO
THAT- THOSE NOISE WITH THE
LIKES. OF WORKING. FOR OVER.
OVER A YEAR WITH THAT LIKE
OBVIOUSLY LIKE. THEY HAD NO
ISSUE UNTIL. SO EITHER WOULD
THAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY GOING
TO WILL RIGHT TO THAT. SO I
WILL- I'LL SPEND IT AND THEY
TOLD THEY TOLD ME- IF I GET MY
LICENSE- AND ALSO SO ON.
NOVEMBER TWENTY SEVEN I WAS
ACTUALLY- DRIVING ON MY WAY TO
THE NBL I JUST HAVE ONE MORE
EXAM TO GO TO GET MY-
CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL DRIVER
PLACES AND- I RECEIVE A PHONE
CALL FROM THE MANAGER UNIVERSAL.
ANI DUE TO- THE ARTISTIC
LICENSE- THEY'RE GONNA
TERMINATE. SO I THOUGHT WAS
REALLY A I'M ON MY WAY TO BE A
BE I'M GONNA HAVE MY LICENSE BY
THE END OF THE DAY ARE. I'LL BE
GOOD TO GO IT IS SET OUT. BILL
WELL THAT'S SOMETHING I WOULD
HAVE TO- SPEAK. SPEAK TO A-
UNIVERSAL BODY. TO US YOU WOULD
HAVE. SEOUL I REALLY I CAN GO
TO YEAH I WAS I WENT HOME- WHEN
I GOT TO THE ONE I GOT TO MY
HOUSE MY LAST PAYCHECK WAS
ALREADY WAITING FOR ME ABOUT
BUT IT'S- BETTER. IT WILL. SO
ALL THE STUFF. JUST THAT WOULD
THEY FOR THE HOLIDAYS AND ALL
THAT- I HAVE CHILDREN THAT I
GOT A SUPPORT- CHAO'S WHATEVER
DAYS WELL. AND I HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO KEEP UP TO DATE. SO NOW
WE'RE JUST WE JUST ORDERED A-
OTHER UNION BUSTING THE- PUBLIC
WHERE I HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN A-
I WAS IN THE JOB. WHILE FOR
LOCALLY FORTY EIGHT AND-
RESIDUE SET OUT. TO SIDE
HEAVILY UNION IN THE COUNTRY
YEAH SO UNIVERSALLY IS A
TEXTBOOK EXAMPLE WHAT
DELEGATION THANK YOU FOR THE
LOOKS LIKE NOT ONLY THAT THEY
FIRED. ME AND ALL MY OTHER
EMPLOYEES FOR THIS FOR A
LIVING- THE PREFERRED TO MOVE
FARTHER BUSINESS TO OTHER
LOCATIONS. WHERE THEY HAVE-
MISCLASSIFIED RIGHT. SO NOT
ONLY ARE THE STOMPING ON MY
RIGHT TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
BUT THEY ARE ACTIVELY BREAKING
THE LAW. AND STEALING THE WAIT
IS THE RIGHTS OF BILLS-
MISCLASSIFIED RIGHT. SO SEVENTY
UNIVERSAL FAXES ARE NOT UNIQUE
THEY ARE JUST ONE COMPANY MONTH.
MANY OTHERS- COMPANIES WORK
CONTINUE. TO LEARN THE POCKETS
OF OUR BREAK OUT MORE WORK. SO
THE LAW RICKY HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR A LONG. TIME THAT THEY'RE
BANNED FROM PROPERTY AND. IT'S
MY HOPE THAT PEOPLE CAN SEE
JUST HOW MUCH UNIVERSAL
VACCINES HAVE HEARD US AND THE
COMMUNITY MY COWORKERS AND I.
ARE STILL FIGHTING TO GET OUR
JOBS BACK. I HOPE TO ONE DAY
MAKE IT TO THE MORE YOU THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR.
THE MY AND I'M THINKING ABOUT
THE DOUBLE AND I WANT TO
COMMEND. FOR BEING A- AMONG
YOUR PEERS AND ALL THESE. TOP
FIVE. TO BE TERMINATED. IS
REALLY SOMETHING THAT. IT'S A
LOT OF THOSE. COOL IT IS ALWAYS
BEST. STILL DO. THANK YOU. I
THANK THE WORKERS FOR BEING
HERE AND SHARING THEIR STORIES-
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE HAD THE
NEVADA CAUCUSES AND BEFORE THE-
NEVADA CAUCUSES- THERE IN LAS
VEGAS THE CULINARY WORK
IMPORTANT UNION. IN IN ABOUT A
IN LAS VEGAS AND I HEARD. RIGHT
BEFORE THE POP THIS IS THE
TESTIMONY MOSTLY LATINO WOMEN.
WHO WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN OF
ORGANIZING UNIONIZED THE HOTEL
IN LAS VEGAS. AND THEY TELL THE
STORY OF BEING ON STRIKE. FOR
SIX YEARS. SIX YEARS BEING ON
STRIKE AGAINST THE HOTEL IN LAS
VEGAS. IN SOME OF THEIR
STRIKERS DIED BUT ALSO A NUMBER
OF CHILDREN WERE BORN IN THOSE
SIX YEARS AND THOSE LATINO
WOMEN OLDER STORIES OF WHAT THE
UNION MEANS THAT THAT. WHAT IT
MEANS TO THAT CAN NOW HAVE
HEALTH INSURANCE. THEY DIDN'T
BEFORE BEING RESPECT. SO I HOPE
THAT EXPERIENCE CAN BE AN
EXAMPLE TO THE WAREHOUSE
WORKERS HERE AND MY QUESTION TO
THE TEAMSTERS WHO HAS THE
TEAMSTERS REPRESENTING THEM AT
THE WAREHOUSE WHAT WAS THE
PROCESS. THAT WAREHOUSE WORKERS
I WENT TO BE ABLE TO USE.
SPEAKING WITH ME ALL RANDY CAME
THAT CAME OUT AND WE GOT
TOGETHER AND WE PUT UP. HE HAD.
WE HAD. REMEMBER WHO'S SO FAR
AS FAR AS TWO THOUSAND SEVEN.
BUT WHEN YOU CAME IN YOU
ORGANIZED THIS ALL GOT TOGETHER
AND YEAH YEAH YEAH. WE ALL CAME
TOGETHER AND WE. HE CAME TO THE
TABLE BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO WE
HAD ANOTHER YOU YOU WIDE W. BUT
WE WANTED TO WITHDRAW FROM THE
WITH THEM THE HAT AND HAVE
RANDY CAN COME ALONG AND JOIN
BEING RANDY CAME WHEN SHE CAME
IN FOR. WELL I HOPE THAT WE CAN
SEE MORE OF THAT HAVE. HERE IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE THE OTHER WAY
AROUND. WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND.
AND TO WORK. FOR US I CAN
ANSWER QUESTION I KNOW A LITTLE
BIT HISTORY AND WHEN ABOUT
DIFFERENT WAY THE ACTUALLY BACK
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS
BY MY. THE ONLY. CONTACT YEAH.
WHAT A GREAT EXAMPLE. THERE'S
NO QUESTION WHEN YOU HAVE I
LOVE THIS CD. STANDS TO THINGS
LIKE THE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND NEEDED THEN OF THAT. BEING
THAT. TELLING BUT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS MAKING SURE
THAT THESE ARE. TAKEN CARE OF I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR STORIES.
I KNOW THAT YOU WANT TO BE PART
OF THE UNION I KNOW THAT YOU
WANT THE REST OF YOUR WORKERS
PART OF THE UNION IT IS A
PROCESS. I HAVE BEEN WITH OTHER
WORKERS. ALSO TERMINATED NOT TO
FOR YOUR WHOLE TERMINATED IT
WAS EIGHT HUNDRED WORKERS FROM
ONE DAY TO ANOTHER THEY WERE
THAT CLOSE TO. VOTING ON IT AND
THEY AGREEMENT AND THEY WERE
ALL TERMINATE ALL ALL EIGHT
HUNDRED. AND WHEN YOU SEE
THINGS LIKE THIS YOU KNOW THAT
ABSOLUTELY WRONG. SO I KNOW
THAT WE WILL BE LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN. HELP THE PROCESS
IT IS ORGANIC IT IS GOING TO
COME FROM. THE UNION RANDY HAS
DONE A MAGNIFICENT JOB- LOCALLY
HERE WITH US AND- SHORT BECAUSE
THE BENEFITS MAKE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE. I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALL THAT- I DON'T HAVE
A QUESTION I DO THE QUESTIONS
OF ALREADY BEEN OUT I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR COMING HAVING
THE COURAGE TO TALK ABOUT NOT
HAVING. A UNION AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU TO TALK ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF HAVING THE UNION WE
ALL KNOW THOSE. AS SHE LAST
MOVIE IS AND- THERE'S A REASON
WHY OF I SET UP THESE PANELS TO
HAVE WORKERS. TALK AFTER
ACADEMICS AND THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN. THE DO THIS STUDY THE
RESEARCH AS POWERFUL AS THAT
RESEARCH THE PRESENTATIONS WERE
FROM THE ACADEMIC. YEAH YOU
ACTUALLY TO HEAR STRAIGHT THE
WORKERS THE GIVEN THE PUT A
FAMILY PUTS UP A FACE THAT'S
BEING TO THOSE NUMBERS AND DATA.
INSIDE ALL OF YOU FOR DO THAT A
ONE FOR. EMPHASIZE AND THAT'LL
WE TALK A DREAM. OF THE TOP
ABOUT. TALK ABOUT TURN. WE TALK
ABOUT WEIGHT STAFF AND ALL
THOSE THINGS. BUT NOT REALLY
BEINGS AS. AND SO WHAT I WANTED
TO YOU CAN THE FOR OF YOU UP
GIVING US A STORY. BUT BECAUSE
OF ALTHOUGH. ALTHOUGH ALL.
LEDGE AND RIGHT. THINGS WE-
NEED TO BE BAY ON DATA. THE
OTHER MEMBERS WE'RE DOING. AND
SO I APPRECIATE ALL THE. WE
SHOULD YOU TWO BROTHERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND SO WE DO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME IF
THERE'S ANYONE THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT- FEEL FREE TO COME TO
THE MICROPHONE THE CAN DO A
MINUTE. AND IT DOES NOT THAT'S
FINE TO GO TO SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS. OKAY SO WE'LL GO TO.
SOME CLOSING COMMENTS AND WHILE
WE START WITH OUR OUR COUNCIL
MEMBERS OF WHAT YOU'RE FOR THE
REFLECTIONS FROM THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU EIGHT IT'S REALLY
SUCH AN HONOR TO HOST YOU HEAR
AND TO LISTEN AND LEARN FROM
ALL OF YOU AND I JUST WANTED TO
SAY I USUALLY SIT. IN THAT SEAT
THERE AT THE VERY END AND THE
STORIES THAT WE HEARD TODAY THE
DATA THAT I'VE LEARNED. I WON'T
FORGET IT ANYTIME SOON. AND IT
WILL BE CERTAINLY A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
AS EARLY AS TUESDAY WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE HOUSING
IN THIS INDUSTRY IT LOOKS LIKE
DIRECTLY IN OUR NEIGHBORS
ACROSS FROM PARKS WHERE
CHILDREN ARE PLAYING AND WHAT
IT'S DOING TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LIVING IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND I CERTAINLY PLEDGE
TO DO MY PART FROM THE DIET
THANKS TO ALL THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING AND YOUR PERSONAL
STORIES. TO DO THE BEST THEY
CAN FOR NEIGHBORHOODS IN OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH COUNSELOR AGAIN THANK
YOU BOTH. FOR BEING HERE STAY
THE WHOLE TIME TO LISTEN TO THE
STORIES AND THE DATA BECAUSE
YOUR VOICE. ESPECIALLY ON THE
CITY COUNCIL. IN THIS REGION.
IN THE CRITICAL TO PARTNERING
WITH US AS WELL AS WHAT YOU CAN
A LOT. THANK YOU SO MEMBERS. I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU THE
PRESENTERS I WANT TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR PROVIDING THE
PANELISTS PROVIDING THIS
INFORMATION. IT'S SO IMPORTANT
AND I LEARNED SOMETHING TODAY.
THAT I DIDN'T KNOW I THOUGHT I
HAD LEARNED EVERYTHING ABOUT
THE STATISTICS. BECAUSE IT'S
SUCH AN IMPORTANT. ISSUE FOR
ME. BUT I LEARNED EVEN MORE
TODAY AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
FOR THE WORKERS THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. IN THE END IT'S-
IT'S OUR WORKERS. AND GET THE
PEOPLE WORE LIVING AROUND THOSE
WAREHOUSES. THAT I AM MOST
CONCERNED WITH. AND FINDING
WAYS TO GET TO UNIONIZE. IS A
TOP PRIORITY. AND FOR THE
PEOPLE LIVING IN THOSE AROUND
THOSE WAREHOUSES. MY TOP
PRIORITY IS TO FIND WAYS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE. TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF TRUCKS COMING IN. REDUCE THE
CLOSENESS TO THE SENSITIVE
AREAS THIS THE CREATE A BUFFER
ZONE SO THAT THE WAREHOUSES ARE
NOT BUILT CLOSE TO THE HOMES
CLOSE SCHOOLS CLOSE TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. WANT TO TELL YOU
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE A
CITY COUNCIL PERSON. TO BE PART
OF THIS BECAUSE THE DECISIONS
ARE MADE LOCALLY. IT MATTERS
WHO YOU ELECT LOCALLY THIS
ISN'T A POLITICAL ANNOUNCEMENT
I'M JUST TELLING YOU THAT THOSE
DECISIONS ARE MADE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. SO HAVING SOMEBODY LIKE
THE SOMEONE NUMBER LIKE THE- OR
TELLING. COUNCIL THE COUNCIL
MEMBER HERE LISTENING TO THIS I
ALREADY KNOW HOW COMMITTED SHE
IS TO THESE TOPICS THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND AT THE
STATE LEVEL I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO. WANNA
THANK- BOTH THE PEOPLE DOING
THE RESEARCH AND THE WORKERS
FOR PRESENTING A VERY VALUABLE
INFORMATION AND I WOULD SAY
THEY PROBABLY GIVEN OUR
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION- OUR
AVAILABILITY OF OPEN SPACE OUT
HERE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE IT
MAY BE INEVITABLE THAT WE HAVE
WAREHOUSES WHAT IS NOT
INEVITABLE I THE CONDITIONS OF
THE WAREHOUSE WORKERS THAT IS
NOT INEVITABLE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE UNDER
OUR CONTROL- IT IS NOT.
ACCEPTABLE TO ME THAT WE ARE
THE FIFTH WORST PLACE IN THE
NATION TO GROW UP. PART OF THAT
IS BECAUSE OF WAGES SO I AM
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR
OF LABOR- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH
KALRA. AND MY COLLEAGUE SAM
GOOD YOU KNOW. A IS TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO. SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU-
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE WORKERS TO
PROVE. THE CONDITIONS TO PROVE.
THE WAGES THAT ARE OUR AGE AND
THE CONDITIONS THAT WORKERS ARE
HAVING TO WORK. AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
BOTH THE BOYS FROM THE MEMBERS
IN THE NIGHT OF THE MATCH TO
SERVE ON THE BUT THEY WERE BOTH.
EVEN THOUGH I KNOW THEY HAD
ENGAGED. TELL ME ACTUALLY
REALLY SCHEDULE THEY GIVE YOU
THIS MORNING. SO THERE'S HERE
BECAUSE THE DOING THE WORK ALSO
I THINK IT WILL BE CRITICAL
PART MYSELF I MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY SENATE TO TAKE FOR THE
ONE YEAR TODAY I WANT TO THANK
THE CITY RIVERSIDE. IT IS AN
STAFF. STREAMING VISUAL TODAY'S
WELL JUST MY STUFF. MAYBE
COMMITTEE HELLO THANK EVERYONE-
THAT WAS HERE. THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION THE A LOT MORE I
KNOW AND I WILL MAKE SURE THAT
WILL MAKE THE PRESENTATIONS
AVAILABLE- TWELVE COLLEAGUES AS
WELL BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION THERE THAT. FORMAL
IN TERMS OF LEGISLATION
REGULATIONS FORCE ALL THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE MADE THAT.
FOUR OF THE FORCE OF THE STORY.
AND SO. I THINK THAT- I DON'T
EASY FOR INFORMATION. ONE WE DO
THEM BECAUSE ALL THE- TIME- WE
DO THEM BECAUSE ONE ACTUALLY
CREATE IDEAS LEGISLATIVE IDEAS
ONE OF MY LOOK FORWARD TO SOLVE
REALLY. AND THE- ISSUE THAT
THAT'S MOVING ALONG. AND I ONE
OF THE LAST THING I WANT TO
MENTION. ALL THE AS WELL AS- A
LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS AND I
HAVE. THE INCLUDING THE DO
WHICH I THINK IS AS CHAIR OF
LABOR THAT I ALWAYS. BUT ISSUE
OF OUR DOES. WHETHER WE HAVE
CONTROL OVER. THE MEDINA. YES
THE WAREHOUSES DE YEAR MAYBE A
FACT OF LIFE QUALITY OF THE
WORK THAT THAT'S ABOUT WE THINK
ABOUT SUBSIDIES ON THE FRONT
END AND ON. COMPANIES SUCH. YOU
KNOW THEY THEY CALLED UNTITLED-
SOMEONE THAT'S ONE OF THE CHILD
AND ALL THE SUDDEN. CORPORATION
THE CALL THE REALITIES OF
TAXPAYER MONEY. AND NOT ONLY
THAT TAXPAYER MONEY TO
ESTABLISH A COMPANY. ON ONE
TAXPAYER MONEY TO SUBSIDIZE THE
WORKERS. I HAD A BILL LAST YEAR
THAT ALTHOUGH THE MAKE IT ALL
THE WAY TO GETTING SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR. THE REQUIREMENTS.
ANY JURISDICTION ANY PUBLISHERS.
THE HOUSING. KEEP ON FIGHTING
ON THE PHONE THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE
HEY HAPPY TO INCENTIVIZE YOUR
GROWTH AS A DEVELOPER WERE
HAPPY TO INCENTIVIZE- QUALITY.
OPTION OF GOOD JOB SO THE KEY
IS GOING TO BE GOOD FOR THE JOB
THIRTY DESTRUCTIVE. THERE'S GOT
TO BE SOME ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
MONEY. AND SO I THINK THAT THAT
IS A LOT THAT WE HAVE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WHAT SAFETY LIKE.
HE'S A WORK ON CAL OSHA ALL
THESE GREAT SUGGESTION WE DO
HAVE A LOT. AND A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WORKABLE BECAUSE
SOME THEY DO IS THEY'LL MAKE IT
UP BY BETWEEN ALL THESE. WE
WANT THE JOBS ONE WE WANT TO
JUST AND- THE ONE THIS WHERE.
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND SO I UP
BEING A RACE THE BOTTOM. WE
HAVE TO DO YEAH YEAH. MAKE IT.
A RACE. A QUALITY JOB SO I TO
THANK ALL OF YOU BEING HERE
NEWS. SHE SOMETIMES AND. OF THE
KIND OF WORK THAT WILL BE TO
HARD WORK IS IT TIME. EXISTENCE
BUT I KNOW THAT WE HAVE. LITTLE
FORTY TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES UP
HERE AND I. THAT'S WITHOUT AND
THERE'S A LOT OF WILL THAT'S
OUT THERE IN THE AUDIENCE AND
AS WELL TO PARTNER WITH US TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE CAN CREATE
THE KIND OF CALIFORNIA- THAT WE
CAN. THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH TO
BE. TODAY GEN.